Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast zu Raumzeit und anderen.
Kosmischen Angelegenheiten in Unterstützung des Planetariums in Berlin,
dem Zeiss-Großplanetarium in Berlin.
Heute sogar in besonderer Unterstützung, denn wir sind heute live auf der Bühne
im Planetarium in Berlin und ich begrüße alle, die heute gekommen sind.
Herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit.
Ja, und heute wollen wir über die Beobachtung des Weltalls sprechen,
wie das ja hier schon öfter geschehen ist.
Ganz konkret wollen wir uns mal anschauen, wie es eigentlich so aussieht.
Was gibt es denn, womit wird denn das Weltall beobachtet?
Und diesmal sind wir nicht im All, sondern wir schauen uns mal ganz konkret
an, wie die Beobachtung vom Boden aussieht.
Und ich freue mich besonders dafür, meinen Gesprächspartner begrüßen zu können für diese Ausgabe.
Ich begrüße herzlich Jochen Liske. Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, Jochen, du bist Astrophysiker, ne?
Richtig.
Und du bist aus Hamburg und du bist dort an der Hamburger Sternwarte,
die aber eigentlich jetzt gar nicht so richtig als Sternwarte arbeitet,
sondern eigentlich vielmehr ein universitärer Teil ist, richtig?
Ganz genau, die Sternwarte hat zwar ursprünglich angefangen,
als eine klassische Sternwarte in Hamburg in den 1820er Jahren schon,
hatte ursprünglich die Aufgabe, Zeit zu messen, so wie fast alle Sternwarten
auf der Welt ursprünglich.
Solche Sternwarten gab es überall in Hafenstädten rings um die Welt und da haben
sie Zeitsignale an die Schifffahrt gegeben. Das war wichtig für die Navigation.
Aber dann irgendwann sind sie natürlich auch in die astrophysikalische Forschung
eingestiegen und sind dann irgendwann aber in den 1960er Jahren zu einem Institut
der Universität Hamburg geworden.
Und was ist dann so deine Aufgabe dort?
Ich bin Professor für Beobachtende Astronomie, das heißt ich unterrichte Astrophysik
an der Uni und forsche natürlich auch.
Ich forsche im Bereich der extragalaktischen Astronomie,
also ich erforsche, wie solche Strukturen wie unsere Milchstraße entstanden
sind und wann sie entstanden sind und beschäftige mich auch mit der Kosmologie,
also mit der Wissenschaft vom Universum als Ganzen.
Ich habe mal auf deiner Homepage ein bisschen rumgegraben, da erzählst du,
was so die eine Hälfte deiner Zeit und die andere Hälfte deiner Zeit frisst
und dann gibt es noch die dritte Hälfte deiner Zeit, in der du versuchst,
dem Rest der Welt zu erklären,
dass Wissenschaft und Astronomie im Besonderen das größte Abenteuer der Welt überhaupt sind.
Ganz genau, ja.
Kannst du das mal näher ausführen?
Naja, damit meine ich, also mit der dritten Hälfte natürlich meine ich,
dass ich dafür eigentlich gar nicht genug Zeit habe und das würde ich eigentlich
gerne noch viel mehr machen.
Aber was ich damit meine natürlich ist, dass die ungefähr 400 Jahre,
die wir jetzt Naturwissenschaft im modernen Sinne betreiben,
dass das doch eine unheimlich erfolgreiche Unternehmung ist,
die die Menschheit da angefangen hat.
Wenn nicht sogar die erfolgreichste Unternehmung.
Und dass es einfach in einem intellektuellen Sinne ein ungeheures Abenteuer
ist, wenn man sich eben auf Forschung einlässt, auf naturwissenschaftliche Forschung einlässt.
Dabei ist es im Prinzip egal, in welchem Feld man unterwegs ist.
Es ist einfach unglaublich spannend, an der Grenze des menschlichen Wissens
zu operieren und zu arbeiten und zu versuchen, diese Grenze nach außen zu verschieben.
Das macht unheimlich viel Spaß und wie gesagt, ich finde es ein großes Abenteuer.
Ja, du bist auch schon immer so ein bisschen als Kommunikator unterwegs gewesen.
Hast du auch mal so einen Hubblecast mitgemacht bei der NASA, stimmt's?
Richtig. Wir haben, wann war denn das?
2007 angefangen mit dem Hubblecast. Das war ein Video-Podcast,
der kam nicht direkt von der NASA, sondern tatsächlich von der ESA eigentlich.
Aber es hatte, wie der Name schon sagte, mit dem Weltraumteleskop Hubble zu tun.
Und da haben wir eben versucht, sozusagen auf ungefähr monatlicher Basis die
neuesten Ergebnisse und Bilder und Ereignisse rund ums Hubble irgendwie an den Mann zu bringen.
Weil das ja ein großes Ding war damals.
Das war damals so, das Hubble ist immer noch ein großes Ding.
Naja, aber es war ja auch so ein richtig so ein, boah, was für ein großes Ding,
nachdem es dann repariert wurde.
Das stimmt, es ist mehrmals repariert worden. Es gibt ja mehrere,
ich glaube fünf insgesamt Servicing-Missions zum Hubble-Weltraum-Teleskop gegeben,
wovon natürlich die erste den meisten in Erinnerung geblieben ist,
weil eben die erste Servicing-Mission den optischen Fehler, den das Teleskop ja leider hatte,
dass diese erste Mission hat diesen optischen Fehler eben ausgleichen können
oder ein Instrument eingebaut,
mit dem dieser Fehler ausgeglichen werden konnte und somit dann erst das Hubble-Weltraumteleskop
so richtig in Fahrt kam und so richtig sein volles Auflösungsvermögen ausspielen konnte.
Das war natürlich spannend, das ist natürlich eine tolle Geschichte,
die so eine Phönix aus der Asche zunächst hatte, für die, die es nicht wissen,
als das Hubble-Weltraumteleskop zuerst gestartet wurde und die ersten Beobachtungen
aufgenommen wurden, stellte man fest, dass es längst nicht die Auflösung hatte.
Also die Bilder hatten längst nicht die Schärfe, die sie eigentlich hätten haben sollen.
Und dann ging das große Rätselraten los und am Kopf gekratzte.
Und dann irgendwann kam man auf den Trichter nach vielen Untersuchungen,
dass eben der Hauptspiegel des Hubble-Weltraumteleskops tatsächlich falsch geschliffen
war. Das war natürlich eine Riesenkatastrophe.
Aber die NASA-Ingenieure sind ja nicht doof. Die haben sich dann schnell was einfallen lassen.
Und dann ist eben mit der ersten Servicing-Mission, die ist dann vorgezogen worden,
wurde das Space Shuttle hochgeflogen, hat das Weltraumteleskop eingefangen und
dann wurde es aufgemacht,
also quasi Operation am offenen Herzen und dann wurde eben CoStar eingebaut
und das war eben eine Optik, die eben diesen Fehler im Schliff des Hauptspiegels ausgleichen konnte,
und dann haben diese Bilder dann endlich die Auflösung eröffnet.
Die sie hätten haben sollen.
Also das Ding hat eine Brille bekommen.
Das Ding hat eine Brille bekommen und was zuerst eben wie eine monumentale Fehlleistung
aussah, wurde dann eben doch noch gerettet durch diese heldenhafte Arbeit und,
seitdem, wie man so schön sagt, der Rest ist Geschichte.
Hubble ist sicherlich das berühmteste Teleskop der Welt, aber möglicherweise
sogar eines der erfolgreichsten wissenschaftlichen Instrumente überhaupt,
die sich die Menschheit jemals hat einfallen lassen.
Und wenn man sich anguckt, Ob das Hubble für einen Einfluss auf die Astrophysik
sowieso, aber auch quasi auch in die populäre Kultur gehabt hat, das ist Wahnsinn.
Man nimmt die berühmte Eingangsszene von dem Film Contact mit Jodie Foster,
diese ganze Eingangsszene, das sind alles Hubble-Aufnahmen.
Und viele dieser Aufnahmen sind ja wirklich ikonografisch geworden,
also das ist schon enorm.
Aber Hubble zeigt natürlich auch schön, was so ein bisschen das Problem ist
mit der Beobachtung des Weltraums. aus dem Weltraum, ist teuer,
man hat da nur einen Schuss und wenn man dann einen Fehler gemacht hat,
dann ist es richtig teuer, den auszubügeln und dann fällt das Ding halt auch
irgendwann wieder runter.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Jahre hat Hubble jetzt noch? Das ist nicht mehr so viel, ne?
Nicht mehr so ewig lang, das ist nicht festgelegt. Hubble wird so lange weiter
betrieben, wie es nicht auseinander fällt, also wie die Komponenten noch mitspielen
und dann wird es irgendwann zum kontrollierten Absturz gebracht werden,
weil Hubble tatsächlich, ist ja tatsächlich groß.
Hubble hat ungefähr die Größe eines Schulbusses ungefähr,
also das ist wirklich ein großes Instrument und das wird nicht komplett verglühen
in der Atmosphäre und deswegen möchte man kein Risiko eingehen,
das soll natürlich nicht irgendwo im bewohnten Gebiet runtergehen und dann wird
es eben kontrolliert über den Pazifik zum Absturz gebracht werden.
Genau, das ist eben eines der Probleme.
War eigentlich das einzige Weltraumteleskop, das man reparieren konnte.
Die meisten Weltraumteleskope kann man ja nicht einfach so hinfliegen,
jetzt sowieso schon mal gar nicht mehr, weil wir keinen Space Shuttle mehr haben.
Also kann man nicht einfach eine neue Brille verpassen. Das ist eben der große
Vorteil der erdgebundenen Astronomie.
Da kann ich ein Teleskop auf der Erde, das kann ich natürlich immer mit der
neuesten Technologie und neuen Instrumenten ausrüsten und somit dem Teleskop
sozusagen neues Leben einhauchen.
Und das ist eben im Weltraum schwierig.
Und vor allem natürlich auch immer so die tollste Computertechnik daneben stellen,
um irgendwie alles rauszuholen, was nur rauszuholen ist.
Es gibt ja noch so ein Zwischending, was ja auch bei Raumzeit schon mal besprochen
wurde, SOFIA, das Teleskop im Flugzeug.
Das ist natürlich auch Bombe, weil man damit eben mal so auf 10.000 Kilometer
herumfliegen kann und damit natürlich eine ganze Menge Probleme,
die man jetzt ganz unten hat oder normalerweise hat, ausbügeln kann bzw.
Einfach überfliegt im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes und dazu eben sich auch noch
optimal ausrichten kann, je nachdem welches Geschehen man gerade so beobachten will.
Aber auch das ist natürlich vergleichsweise teuer im Betrieb und man muss da
halt eine Menge Organisatorisches leisten.
Deswegen gibt es die bodengestützte Astronomie und die gibt es ja auch schon
ewig. Womit fing es eigentlich an?
Ja, streng genommen vor gut 400 Jahren wurde das Teleskop erfunden,
so um 1610 herum, wurde das Teleskop erfunden in Holland,
so ganz genau weiß man es nicht, aber vermutlich von einem Menschen namens Hans
Lippersay, da gab es dann sogar einen Patentstreit drum.
Aber Galileo hat dann eben sich schnell, hat davon gehört, hat davon Wind bekommen,
hat sich dann sehr schnell sein eigenes Teleskop gebaut und Galileo wird heute
meistens als derjenige geführt, der eben zum ersten Mal mit dem Teleskop dann
in den Himmel geblickt hat und,
Dann hat er direkt sehr, sehr viele Dinge entdeckt, die so quasi alles auf den
Kopf gestellt haben, was man damals dachte, über das Universum zu wissen.
Also Beispiele, er hat Sonnenflecken entdeckt, was der These zuwider lief,
dass alle Himmelskörper perfekte Sphären seien.
Er hat die Phasen der Venus entdeckt, was im Prinzip das heliozentrische Weltbild untermauerte.
Er hat vier Monde um den Jupiter entdeckt, die heute nach ihm benannt sind,
die galiläischen Monde, was zeigte, dass es auch andere Zentren der Bewegung
geben kann im Universum außer der Erde halt.
Also das ging Schlag auf Schlag direkt.
Die auf dem Zeitpunkt noch als das Zentrum der Bewegung galt.
Genau. Ja, und danach gab es natürlich große Entwicklungen, dann wurden dann
immer mehr Teleskope gebaut, zunächst natürlich als Linsenteleskope.
Dass diese Technologie ging dann irgendwann, lief dann so ein bisschen vor die
Wand, weil eben Linsen schon ihre Limitationen haben, wie groß ich sie eben bauen kann.
Die werden dann irgendwann zu schwer, fangen an, sich unter ihrem eigenen Gewicht zu verformen.
Und das Blöde an der Linse ist ja, dass ich eben durchgucken will.
Das heißt, ich kann eine Linse nur am Rand festhalten.
Und das ist dann eben schwierig, eine Deformation auszugleichen.
Und dann kann man eben auch auf den Trichter eben, dass ich alles,
was man mit einer Linse machen kann, eigentlich auch mit einem Spiegel machen kann.
Und so kam man dann zu den Reflektoren, den reflektierenden Teleskopen,
wo die Linsen eben durch Spiegel ersetzt wurden.
Und dann wurden sie dann eben auch langsam größer.
Berühmte Teleskope sind zum Beispiel das 100-Zoll-Teleskop auf dem Mount Wilson,
dann später das Hale, das 5-Meter-Teleskop, das Hale-Teleskop in Amerika.
Und dann eben kam so die Ära der 4-5 Meter Teleskope und heute sind wir eben
in der Ära der 8-10 Meter Teleskope.
Das sind die größten optischen und infraroten Teleskope, die wir heute auf der
Erde haben. Dafür haben wir eine ganze Menge mittlerweile.
Die ersten waren die beiden KEK-Teleskope auf Hawaii, KEK 1 und KEK 2, gut 10 Meter groß.
Die Europäer haben dann relativ schnell nachgezogen. Die europäische Südsternwarte
hat dann vier 8,2 Meter große Teleskope gebaut.
Die stehen in Chile am Paranal Observatorium. Aber es gibt noch eine ganze Reihe anderer Teleskope.
Die allergrößten, die wir heute haben, da gibt es zwei von.
Das South African Large Telescope, das in Südafrika steht.
Das ist 10,4 Meter groß. Und dann gibt es ein sehr ähnliches Teleskop auf den
Kanarischen Inseln, auf La Palma. das Gran Telescopio Canarias, GTC heißt das genau.
Bevor wir die alle nochmal durchgehen,
Vielleicht nochmal so zu der eigentlichen Problematik. Ich meine jetzt,
okay, man ist dann irgendwann auf die Spiegel gewechselt. Das ist jetzt schon
eine relativ neue Entwicklung eigentlich, oder?
Ja, das war so am Anfang des 20.
Jahrhunderts hat man angefangen, als zum Beispiel die Hamburger Sternwarte,
von der wir eben gesprochen haben, an ihren heutigen Standort gezogen ist um 1910.
Da wurde dort zwar noch ein großer Refraktor, also ein großes Linsenteleskop
von 60 Zentimeter Größe gebaut, aber dann fing man ziemlich schnell an,
eben schon die Spiegelteleskope zu bauen.
Weil es einfach, wie gesagt, mit diesen Linsen hat man eben dieses Problem,
wenn ich ein Objekt lange integrieren will auf einem Objekt,
also lange beobachten will, ich folge es über den Himmel, über längere Zeit hinweg.
Man integriert auf dem Objekt?
Also man integriert Licht, man sammelt Licht, man belichtet.
Okay, integriert. Man belichtet einfach. Und dann folge ich eben dem Objekt
am Himmel, dann bewegt sich natürlich das Teleskop. Die Schwerkraft greift an
einem anderen Winkel am Teleskop an und verzieht somit und verdreht das Teleskop.
Und je größer das Teleskop ist, desto schwerer ist es und desto größer wird
an dem Teleskop gezogen.
Also das ist gar nicht so, ich dachte immer, das Problem wäre sowas überhaupt
groß genug zu bauen und dann die Qualität sicherzustellen, aber das Problem
ist dann einfach die Gravitation.
Nein, das sind beides Probleme. Auch das ist ein großes. Also Linsen,
die größer sind als, sag mal, 1,10 Meter oder so, sind auch heute noch nicht ganz einfach zu bauen.
Das ist heute wieder aktuell zum großen Durchmüsterungsteleskopen,
die also ein sehr großes Gesichtszelt haben und die große Teile des Himmels
gleichzeitig abbilden wollen.
Diese Teleskope brauchen Korrekturlinsen irgendwo in ihrem Starngang.
Und die müssen heutzutage tatsächlich wieder relativ groß sein.
Und das ist tatsächlich mit die schwierigsten Teile an diesen Teleskopen, die zu bauen.
Also es ist beides ein Problem, sowohl eben das Gewicht als auch eben die optische
Qualität von so großen optischen Elementen sicherzustellen. Das ist nicht so ganz einfach.
Aber die Reflektoren sind dann im Prinzip so der neue Königsweg gewesen.
Damit konnte man dann überhaupt erstmal eine ganz andere Art der Beobachtung realisieren.
Der Witz ist eben der, dass ich einen Spiegel nicht nur am Rand festhalten kann,
sondern auch von hinten festhalten kann.
Das heißt, den kann ich ja schön einbetten in ein Gestell und kann es eben viel
besser festhalten und kann somit das ganze Ding eben viel besser stabilisieren.
Damit war man einen großen Schritt weiter, dann konnte man sehr viel größere
Teleskope bauen, eben wie gesagt vier, fünf Meter große Teleskope.
Und dann versuchte man eben die Teleskope immer noch so steif wie möglich zu
bauen, damit sie sich eben nicht verbiegen.
Damit sie eben nicht die innere Position haben.
Genau, und dass eben die verschiedenen Spiegel, die im Teleskop sind,
ihre relative Lage zueinander sich eben nicht verändern und der einzelne Spiegel
seine Form eben auch nicht verändert.
Das ist aber gar nicht so leicht. wenn ich so einen 5 Meter Spiegel habe, der wiegt schon mal was.
Die sind ja auch nicht jetzt, darf ich mir ja nicht so einen Badezimmerspiegel
darunter vorstellen, sondern das Glas von so einem 5 Meter Spiegel darf dann
durchaus schon mal so einen halben Meter dick sein bei den alten Teleskopen.
Heutzutage bei dem VLT hier, also bei dem Very Large Telescope,
also den vier, acht Meter Teleskopen, die wir haben. Wie gesagt, der Hauptspiegel.
Wenn wir hier sagen, Hier wurde es gerade durch das Planetarium dahin versetzt.
Das können wir natürlich jetzt im Podcast nicht so direkt drüber bringen.
Genau, aber bei diesen 8-Meter-Spiegeln, wie gesagt, das ist ein Stück Glaskeramik,
8,2 Meter im Durchmesser.
Die sind nur 20 Zentimeter dick.
Nur, das ist extrem dünn. Und früher waren die Spiegel eben sehr,
sehr viel dicker, weil man eben auch versucht hat, sie daran zu hindern,
sich in ihrer Form zu verändern.
Wenn ich sage, sich in ihrer Form zu verändern, darf man sich jetzt nicht vorstellen,
dass sie wirklich so durchbiegen, sodass ich das sehen könnte.
Denn es reicht schon, wenn sich ein Spiegel in der Größenordnung von der Wellenlänge
des Lichts verbiegt oder seine Form verändert.
Das heißt, wenn ein Spiegel schon seine Form in der Größenordnung von einigen
zehn Nanometern verändert, dann reicht das schon, um das Bild,
das dieses Teleskop liefert, quasi kaputt zu machen.
Das heißt, die Bildqualität zu zerstören, das reicht schon. Das heißt,
wir reden wirklich kaputt.
Im Sinne von überhaupt nicht mehr zu gebrauchen oder nur nicht so gut?
Das geht bis hin zu gar nicht mehr zu gebrauchen, dass ich eben nicht mehr ein
scharfes Bild von einem Stern habe, sondern dass ich nur noch eine Banane habe.
Bananen im Weltall.
Genau, Bananen im Weltall. Also in dem Moment, wo ich anfange,
eben die abzuweichen von der Form, die ein Spiegel tatsächlich haben sollte,
also abzuweichen in der Größenordnung von einigen 10 Nanometern,
dann kriege ich nur noch Bananen, dann kriege ich keine scharfen Bilder mehr.
Bananen im Weltall. Was mich jetzt noch mal frage ist, also ich erinnere mich,
ich hatte ja schon mal deinen Kollegen Markus Brücken hier bei Raumzeit,
haben uns über Galaxien, Kosmologie unterhalten,
sein Spezialfeld und haben auch kurz über die Sternwarte gesprochen und ich
glaube, ich erinnere mich, der erste Standort war in St. Pauli, ne?
Genau, der war im Millantor.
Und da war es dann zu hell? Oder zu laut?
Ja, es wurde zu laut und zu viel Vibrationen auch. Zu viel Vibrationen,
zu laut, zu, die Luft war ja auch nicht gerade rein damals.
Man meint immer Smog seine moderne Erfindung, aber Smog hat es auch früher schon gegeben.
Wenn man sich vorstellt, dass jeder
mit Cola heizt, dann kann man sich vorstellen, wie es ausgesehen hat.
Und vor allem, was dann eben passierte, auch irgendwann ist,
dass die Sternwarte dort am Hafen nicht mehr gebraucht wurde,
weil eben mittlerweile die Uhr erfunden wurde.
Also Uhren, die transportabel waren und die ich mit auf ein Schiff nehmen konnte
und auch auf einem Schiff noch die genaue Zeit anzeigen konnte.
Denn wie gesagt, die Zeit brauche ich eben für die Navigation,
um meine Länge, den Längengrad bestimmen zu können.
Und als ich das dann hatte...
Deswegen gab es sozusagen primär die Sternwarte. Es war gar nicht so,
wir wollen jetzt mal das Weltall beobachten und lass doch mal die Wahrheit über
das Leben herausfinden. Nö, wir wollen nur wissen, wie spät es ist.
Ja, ganz genau. Das war ursprünglich der Sprung. Man kann sich den Spaß machen,
wer eine Hafenstadt kennt...
Glück gehabt, dass das überlebt hat.
Ja, wer Hafenstädte kennt, wer mal, keine Ahnung, in Edinburgh,
in Sydney, überall auf der Welt hat es das gegeben, ein bisschen in Brasilien,
da hat es eben Sternwarten in der Nähe von den Häfen gegeben.
Und die haben dann immer, einmal am Tag haben die ein Zeitsignal gegeben.
Also natürlich nicht am Telefon, sondern da gab es ein optisches Zeitsignal,
da wurde ein großer Mast gebaut und an dem Mast wurde in der Regel ein Ball
dann hochgezogen und der wurde dann Punkt und Punkt, zwölf Mittags,
wurde dieser Ball fallen gelassen.
Und dann haben die Leute auf den Schiffen gestanden, haben das beobachtet und
haben danach ihre Uhren gestellt sozusagen, die sie an Bord hatten. Jetzt ist es zwölf Uhr.
Und wenn man den Ball nicht, für die Schiffe, die den Ball nicht sehen konnten,
wurde dann meistens noch eine Kanone abgefeuert, damit man es eben auch hören
konnte. Dann musste man noch die Laufzeit des Schalls noch berücksichtigen.
Aha, ich bin so und so weit weg, habe keine Ahnung, zwei, drei Sekunden Laufzeit,
dann muss ich das noch berücksichtigen.
Cool. Aber worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte ist, nicht alle Standorte sind
optimal für eine Beobachtung.
Also jetzt, okay, St. Pauli, das mag jetzt mehrere Gründe gehabt haben,
warum man da nicht mehr hin könnte. Dann ist es ja nach Bergedorf gezogen.
Da ist ja wahrscheinlich mittlerweile auch nicht mehr so dunkel,
wie es mal war, nehme ich mal an.
Nee, überhaupt gar nicht.
Genau, überhaupt gar nicht. Worauf ich hinaus will ist, wenn man jetzt das Weltall
beobachten will, wo muss man eigentlich hin?
Also von wo hat es in den letzten 100 Jahren Sinn gemacht und auf welche Orte hat sich das reduziert?
Also die Lichtverschmutzung ist klar, das ist so ein Thema, haben wir ja hier
in Deutschland eigentlich auch.
Dauerthema hier im Planetarium, Mach mal jeder mal sein Handy an und man sieht
schon gar nichts mehr hier von der Projektion.
Und es gibt halt noch so ein paar Lichtnaturschutzparks, ich weiß nicht genau,
wie die korrekt heißen, wo es halt mal so richtig schön dunkel ist.
Aber so für die professionelle Astronomie ist das doch ein richtiges Problem.
Genau, also jetzt kann man sich mal überlegen, was ich denn brauche,
um wirklich gut das Weltall beobachten zu können. Lichtverschmutzung ist ein Thema.
Klar, ich muss also möglichst weit weg von der Zivilisation,
weil Straßenlampen, Straßenlaternen, Industriegebäude, Werbung und so weiter,
das gibt alles unheimlich viel Licht nach oben ab, das stört enorm.
Also man muss weit weg von der Zivilisation.
Wäre natürlich auch nicht schlecht, wenn ich irgendwo in der Gegend wäre,
wo ich nicht allzu viel Bewölkung habe.
Also möglichst viele klare Nächte ohne Bewölkung ist natürlich auch gut.
Und dann kommen wir eben zu dem quasi wichtigsten Faktor, ist die Atmosphäre.
Also das große Problem ist ja, wenn ich vom Erdboden aus ins Weltall gucke,
dann ist das so ein bisschen so, als wenn man am Boden eines Schwimmbads sitzt und nach draußen guckt.
Wenn die Oberfläche des Wassers nicht perfekt still ist, sondern es da einige
Wellen drauf gibt, dann sehe ich die Außenwelt total verzerrt.
Und genau das Gleiche passiert eben auch, wenn ich durch die Atmosphäre hindurch gucke.
Die Atmosphäre ist auch nicht perfekt still, sondern in der Atmosphäre sind
immer Turbulenzen unterwegs.
Das heißt, man hat immer Luftpakete mit unterschiedlichen Temperaturen,
unterschiedlichem Druck und daher mit unterschiedlichem Brechungsindex.
Und deswegen, wenn also ein Lichtstrahl durch die Atmosphäre geht,
dann breitet der sich tatsächlich nicht total gerade aus, sondern tanzt so ein bisschen hin und her.
Und das hat einfach zur Folge, dass wenn ich mir eben einen Stern angucke,
dass das Bild dieses Sterns, das ich mit einem Teleskop machen kann,
ein klein bisschen verschmiert ist.
Und das Bild ist nicht so scharf, wie es eigentlich sein könnte.
Und dieses Verschmieren, das nennt man in der Astronomie das Seeing.
Und dieses Seeing hängt von diversen Dingen ab.
Aber unter anderem hängt es natürlich davon ab, wie viel Luft ich denn eigentlich
zwischen mir und der Atmosphäre habe und dem Weltall habe.
Die Atmosphäre ist ja nicht unbedingt dick, ungefähr 100 Kilometer dick.
Und wenn ich eben schon mal oben auf den Berg gehen kann und den dichtesten
Teil der Atmosphäre, der hier unten auf Meereshöhe ist, den schon mal hinunter
mir lassen kann, dann habe ich natürlich schon mal was gewonnen.
Also da macht jetzt auch mal 1000 Meter mehr oder weniger schon eine Menge aus.
Das macht durchaus schon was aus, weil wir ja eben hier unten im dichtesten
Teil der Atmosphäre sind. Und wenn ich eben ein paar Kilometer hochgehen kann,
das macht durchaus schon mal was aus.
Und dann hat es eben auch was mit der Trockenheit der Luft zu tun.
Je trockener es ist, je weniger Wasserdampf in der Atmosphäre ist, das ist auch gut.
Denn die Atmosphäre verzerrt nicht nur das Licht, das ich sehen kann,
sondern die Atmosphäre absorbiert ja auch jede Menge Licht.
Es wird ja tatsächlich von dem gesamten elektromagnetischen Spektrum nur sehr,
sehr wenig durchgelassen.
Also das optische Licht natürlich, das Licht, das wir mit unseren Augen wahrnehmen
können, das wird durchgelassen von der Atmosphäre.
Und es werden Radiostrahlen durchgelassen, aber der Rest nicht.
Und ultraviolettes Licht?
Ja, knapp. Also da gibt es dann die Grenze, genau, beim Übergang zum UV.
Oder zum fernen UV, da ist dann die Grenze, was durchgelassen wird.
Das ist natürlich auch gesund so, wenn das nicht so wäre und Röntgenstrahlen
von der Sonne durchgelassen wären, das wäre natürlich für uns äußerst ungesund.
Schon das UV-Licht ist ja einigermaßen ungesund für uns.
Aber je weniger Wasserdampf, desto weniger wird eben absorbiert.
Deswegen wird weniger im Infraroten-Bereich absorbiert, desto weiter kann ich
uns ins UV reindrücken und desto besser sind eben die Bedingungen.
Und dann eben, wie gesagt, wir haben eben von der Verschmierung des Lichts eben
von der Verschmierung der Sterne gesprochen und da gibt es eben Orte auf der
Welt, wo dieses Verschmieren sehr viel weniger auftritt als andere Orte.
Also wenn ich Orte, an denen der Fluss der Atmosphäre, sozusagen die Strömung
in den oberen Teilen der Atmosphäre besonders aufbricht.
Glatt sind, besonders laminar sind, dort kriege ich besonders gute Bedingungen.
Dort kann ich besonders scharfe Bilder vom Universum machen.
Das sind eben die Orte, die man sich aussucht.
Und welche Orte sind denn das?
Da kann man sich überlegen, wo das stattfindet. Die besten,
geografischen Gegebenheiten, die sowas hergeben, sind Inseln,
auf denen hohe Berge stehen, das sind dann meistens Vulkane,
in temperierten Ozeanen.
Und da ist eben vor allem Hawaii zu nennen, aber die Kanaren sind ein anderes
Beispiel, aber Hawaii ist so das Beste.
Auf Hawaii gibt es den Mauna Kea, der ist ein Aloshnal-Vulkan,
der ist gut 4000 Meter hoch.
Und das ist so ziemlich der beste Standort auf der nördlichen Halbkugel.
Der ist nicht auf der Hauptinsel, ist das seine eigene Insel?
Genau, seine eigene Insel.
Ah ja, okay. Also da gibt es auch nichts anderes als den Vulkan.
Naja, doch, es gibt schon noch, also in Hilo gibt es schon noch Locations von
der Uni Hamburg, äh, Uni Hamburg, soll ich schon sagen, Uni Hawaii.
Explosieren wir uns von der Uni Hamburg, das wäre schön. Von der Uni Hawaii.
Aber auf diesem Vulkan lässt es jedem sehr gut Astronomie machen und da sind
eben nicht nur die Amerikaner vertreten, sondern auch die Japaner und die Briten
und weiß ja geil wer alles noch.
Also da ist ein großer Astronomie-Park, was auch zu Verstimmungen mit der einheimischen
Bevölkerung geführt hat.
Letztes Jahr hat man da viel drüber lesen können in der Presse.
Also das ist ein super Ort auf der Nordhalbkugel und auf der Südhalbkugel.
Moment, ist das der Einzige auf der Nordhalbkugel?
Das ist der Beste auf der Nordhalbkugel, nicht der Einzige. Aber wie gesagt,
die Kanarischen Inseln ist ein anderes Beispiel, ist auch ein guter Standort.
Wir reden wohlgemerkt hier von Standorten für die optische und infrarote Astronomie.
Für Radioastronomie ist es das was ganz anderes.
Radioastronomie kann man auch prima aus Deutschland machen. Für Radioastronomie
spielt nicht so sehr die Atmosphäre eine Rolle, sondern wie viele menschengemachte Störsignale es gibt.
Und die gibt es natürlich jede Menge. Wenn ich irgendwo in die Wüste gehe, ist es besser.
Aber es gibt auch jede Menge Störsignale, die eben von Satelliten ausgehen.
Also GPS zum Beispiel ist echt ein Problem für Radioastronomie.
Die GPS-Satelliten und die Europäischen Galilee-Satelliten.
Das ist nicht schön.
Schönes Navis.
Eine schöne Anekdote aus der Fraktion ist, dass in der Nähe von Bonn,
in der Eifel, steht das Effelsberg-Teleskop.
Das war lange Zeit das größte, vollbewegliche Radioteleskop der Welt.
Kürt der Max-Planck-Gesellschaft. 100 Meter groß. Wäre mal da gewesen,
das ist ein beeindruckendes,
Ding. Und da hatten die mal das Problem, dass es zu bestimmten Tageszeiten zu
besonders viel Störsignalen kam.
Und dann hat man sich das näher angeguckt und hat festgestellt,
dass vor allem so morgens so um halb neun, neun und dann wieder nachmittags um fünf war.
Und dann kam man auf den Trichter, dass diese Störsignale von den Funkschlüsseln
der Autos kamen, als die Mitarbeiter halt morgens zur Arbeit kamen und nachmittags
wieder nach Hause gefahren sind.
Da hat halt ein Hersteller sich nicht daran gehalten und hat verbotenerweise
eine Funkfrequenz benutzt, die eigentlich der Astronomie vorbehalten ist.
Also die Funkfrequenzen werden ja vergeben.
Ab alle paar Jahre werden die Mobilfunkfrequenzen wieder versteigert und so
weiter, die sind ja heiß begehrt.
Und diese Funkfrequenzen, das ist halt begrenzt. Aber es gibt einige Fenster,
die eben für die Astronomie freigehalten werden.
Die sind natürlich heiß begehrt und wir armen Astronomen,
Man muss sich das immer vorstellen, nicht?
Aliens und dann so, nee, neues Auto.
Genau, nee, neues Auto. Oder kommt eben, keine Ahnung, O2 oder die Telekom und
legt ein paar Milliarden auf den Tisch und wir Astronomen, aber wir wollen auch
noch was sehen können. Bitte, bitte, lass uns was frei.
Ja, LTE frisst mich jetzt auch weiter.
Aber gut, das ist wie die Radioastronomie, das ist was ganz anderes.
So, also nochmal, jetzt wieder zurück zur optischen Astronomie.
Wir hatten auf der Nordhalbkugel eben Hawaii.
Und eben auf der Südhalbkugel ist eben der beste Standort in Chile.
In der Atacama-Wüste. Das ist eine der trockensten Gegenden der Welt mit sehr
geringer Luftfeuchtigkeit.
Und da gibt es eben diese schöne klimatische Begebenheit, dass eben vor der
Küste Chiles fließt der Humboldt-Strom.
Und der ist sehr kalt, der hat nur 12 Grad.
Das führt dazu, in Chile gibt es zwar wunderschöne Strände, aber man kann leider
nicht schwimmen, weil es eben eiskalt ist.
Also den Fehler habe ich auch mal begangen. Bin am Strand, dachte, oh geil.
Klamotten aus, baden ins Wasser rein.
Aber dieser Humboldt-Strom sorgt dafür, dass die darüber liegenden Luftschichten sehr kalt sind.
Und die darüber rum wieder liegenden Luftschichten sind tatsächlich viel wärmer.
Das heißt, ich habe eine Inversionslage. Normalerweise ist es ja kalt oben,
warm unten. Und hier habe ich jetzt diese Inversionslage.
Das ist immer das, was dann so Smog...
Genau, wenn man das hier an Land hat, dann bewegt sich erst mal gar nichts.
Und das ist dort ein dauerhafter Zustand.
Das heißt, die Feuchtigkeit, die aus dem Meer aufsteigt, die kann gar nicht hochsteigen.
Die bleibt immer über dem Meer. Und die Wolken, die sich über dem Meer bilden,
können es sozusagen nicht an Land schaffen.
Und das ist sozusagen die westliche Begrenzung.
Warte mal, warum können die Wolken nicht an Land schaffen?
Weil obendrüber die Glocke der warmen Luft liegt.
Obendrüber ist sozusagen eine Glocke, die die Wolken über dem Meer halten.
Also wodurch halten sie die da?
Weil sie nicht aufsteigen können, weil obendrüber die warme Luft ist.
Und sie müssen aufsteigen, damit sie irgendwo anders hinkommen können.
Das ist die westliche Begrenzung und auf der östlichen Begrenzung sind halt die Anden.
Die sind halt mit 5000, 6000 Meter hohen Bergen und da bleibt das ganze Wetter,
das aus Bolivien rüberkommt, bleibt an diesen Anden hängen und regnet sich da ab.
Und in der Mitte habe ich dann eben Chile, diesen sehr schmalen Landstreifen,
ein quasi eindimensionales Land, fährt immer nur rauf und runter und sobald
man rechts und links fährt, falle ich irgendwie ins Wasser oder ich habe einen
riesen Berg vor der Nase.
Ich war mal in Kolumbien und da hatte ich auch noch mal diese Gelegenheit,
mal so einmal über diesen Andenflügel rüber zu gehen. Das ist irgendwie unfassbar.
Ja, also man fährt so, man ist ja relativ hoch gelegen und es ist doch recht kühl.
Man denkt ja immer so, Südamerika und so voll warm und so, aber da so Bogota,
die Gegend und so, ist fast wie hier.
So und dann fährt man halt so mit dem Auto so mal eben so einmal so hups über den Hügel rüber.
Dann geht es irgendwie zehn Kilometer nach unten und man kann so richtig auf
der Uhr so mitzählen. Und so jede Minute ist es ein Grad wärmer.
Bis man so in der Sauna landet.
Das ist wirklich mega krass. Also da merkt man mal, das ist sozusagen diese Besonderheit.
Also die Atacama-Wüste ist trocken, weil Chile generell trocken ist,
aber die Atacama-Wüste ist auch nochmal extra trocken, oder?
Genau, dieser Teil, also nicht alles Chile, also unten in Patagonien ist es
ja überhaupt nicht trocken, aber dieser Teil eben Chiles, dieser nördliche Teil
Chiles, der ist extrem trocken und dort gibt es eben dann eben auch diese,
Berge sozusagen, die Vorläufer der Anden eben, da gibt es eben Berge,
die eben eine vernünftige Höhe haben, dass man dort noch arbeiten kann,
eben, sag mal so, um die 3000 Meter und das sind einfach perfekte Standorte,
um dort Astronomie zu betreiben, weil es da eben ja auch, man ist da tatsächlich
auch in der Wüste, das heißt, es gibt keine,
Lichtverschmutzung, keine menschlichen Siedlungen halt in der Nähe,
da kann man eben Berge finden, die wirklich am Arsch der Welt sind,
man ist eben auf 3000 Meter Höhe, hat das über sich, Man hat 300,
ich sag mal, um die 340 klaren Nächte im Jahr.
Also sehr wenig, man verliert sehr wenig Zeit.
Was ist in den anderen 600?
340, also in den anderen 20, also in ungefähr 20 Nächten hat man dann schon
eben Bewölkung auch mal.
Und dann zwei Jahre regnet es.
Ja, also das Regen kommt selten vor. Hatten wir jetzt kürzlich, ging durch die Presse.
Wenn es da mal regnet, dann blüht die Atacama-Wüste auf mit einem Schlag. Das ist ganz irre.
Ich habe es selbst nie gesehen, nur auf Fotos gesehen.
Das ist dann wirklich ein verrücktes Erlebnis.
Aber ja genau, also deswegen ist und dann und diese ganzen klimatischen Bedingungen
haben dann auch noch zur Folge, dass ich eben diese wunderbar stille Atmosphäre
da eben in Chile habe und das alles,
diese ganze Kombination von
Faktoren führt eben dazu, dass es da in Chile quasi unschlagbar gut ist.
Da unten treiben ja verschiedenste Organisationen deswegen auch ihr Unwesen.
Das ist ja die von dir schon erwähnte Südsternwarte, die europäische Südsternwarte, aber auch NASA etc.
Ich glaube, es sind mehr oder weniger alle dort unten. Oder gibt es da irgendwie eine Ausnahme?
Ja, genau. Es gibt verschiedene Observatorien. Die Amerikaner sind zuerst auf
den Trichter gekommen, dass es da so gut war, in den 60er Jahren.
Und das war gerade, als die Europäische Südschweinwarte den Standort für ihr
erstes großes Teleskop, das 3,6 Meter Teleskop, gesucht hat.
Und die haben zuerst in Südafrika gesucht und dann haben sie eben gehört,
oh Mensch, da oben in Chile ist viel besser und sind dann sehr schnell umgeschwenkt und auf Chile.
Wie gesagt, die Amerikaner haben Observatorien da, es gibt kanado-französische
Kooperationen da, das CFHT,
also es treiben sich alle möglichen darum.
Aber die ESO spielt dann eine ziemlich große Rolle.
Ja, die ESO, also das ist die Europäische Südsternland, das European Southern
Observatory, die spielen da eine große Rolle.
Die ESO fing an, wie gesagt, in den 60er Jahren mit dem LACIA-Observatorium
und dann in den 90er Jahren kam das Paranal-Observatorium dazu,
was man hier eben gerade im Dom sieht, was unsere Hörer natürlich nicht sehen können.
Das war also das zweite Observatorium. Dann wurde zusammen in einer internationalen
Kooperation zusammen mit den Amerikanern, aber auch mit Japan und Taiwan noch
ein neues Radioteleskop gebaut, auch in Chile,
ALMA, das Atacama Large Millimeter and Submillimeter Array.
Das wurde auf einem ganz besonderen Ort gebaut, auch in der Atacama-Wüste,
aber nicht auf einem Berg per se, sondern auf einem Hochplateau.
Und zwar auf einem Hochplateau in einer Höhe von 5000 Metern.
Und wer schon mal auf 5000 Metern gewesen ist, der weiß, dass das kein Zuckerschlecken ist.
Also auf 5000 Metern ist der Luftdruck nur noch die Hälfte von dem bei normalen Null.
Ich bin einmal da oben gewesen, habe mich ein paar Stunden da oben rumgetrieben
und danach hatte ich Monsterkopfschmerzen.
Also da oben, wer da ernsthaft arbeiten muss, die Ingenieure,
die an den Antennen da arbeiten, die tragen alle Sauerstoffmasken,
weil Sauerstoffmangel führt zu Konzentrationsschwächen und zu Fehlern.
Und wenn man mit so einem 100-Tonnen-Teleskop hantiert, sollte man besser keine Fehler machen.
Das heißt, die tragen da solche Sauerstoffmasken. Das heißt,
das muss man ein bisschen abwägen natürlich auch.
Man will eigentlich möglichst hoch, um möglichst wenig Atmosphäre zwischen sich
und dem Weltraum zu haben.
Aber irgendwo gibt es eben auch eine Grenze. Man muss ja auch noch irgendwie dort arbeiten können.
Und da gibt es dann eben auch Grenzen.
Du warst ja selber jahrelang bei der ESO.
Erzähl doch nochmal so ein bisschen, was ist so die Intention dieser Organisation?
Also ESA ist ja schon so ein bisschen unbekannt, ändert sich vielleicht ein wenig,
aber bei ESO denkt man dann immer so, ah ja, ist das so die jüdische Volksfront
von Judea. Die sitzen da drüben. Ja, genau.
Hat ja damit nicht unmittelbar was zu tun.
Genau, das sollte man erstmal klarstellen. Das sind tatsächlich zwei unterschiedliche Organisationen.
Die ESA ist die European Space Agency und die EESO ist das European Southern Observatory.
Und wenn ich einen Euro für jedes Mal hätte, dass ein Journalist die Beine durcheinander
wirft, dann wäre ich deutlich reicher. Genau, das sind zwei vollkommen unterschiedliche Organisationen.
Die ESO hat den Auftrag, bodengebundene Observatorien zu planen,
zu bauen und zu betreiben.
Und das macht sie für die Astronomen in den Mitgliedsländern.
Also die ESO ist eine internationale Organisation, die hat 15 Mitgliedstaaten,
hat übrigens nichts mit, obwohl sie das europäisch im Namen hat,
hat es überhaupt nichts mit der EU oder so weiter zu tun.
Diese Organisationen, genau wie die ESA, sind einfach sogenannte multilaterale Organisationen.
Das heißt, da sind ein Haufen Nationen, haben sich an einen Tisch gesetzt und
haben gesagt, wir wollen ein internationales Institut gründen,
das mit dem und dem Auftrag. Davon gibt es mehrere.
Das CERN ist ein anderes Institut, das man wahrscheinlich kennt,
Teilchenbeschleuniger, LHC.
CERN, die ESA, die ESO, das EMBL, European Molecular Biology Lab und jetzt ist
gerade in Hamburg eine neue Organisation da hinzukommen, das X-Ray Laser.
Davon gibt es also fast zwei Handvoll solcher Organisationen.
Die ESO ist eben eine davon.
Eher eine der kleineren kommt im Verhältnis zur CERN oder zur ESA,
ist die ESO relativ klein.
Genau, also wie gesagt, der Auftrag ist, Observateuren planen, bauen und zu betreiben.
Und benutzen tun das dann eben die Astronomen an den Universitäten und Forschungsinstituten
Europas und der Mitgliedsländer.
Wie bist du denn da hingekommen? Du hast ja, glaube ich, in Schottland lange
Zeit studiert, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Nee, ich studiert nicht, aber an der Uni geforscht.
An der Uni geforscht, achso, aber in Deutschland studiert und dann aber zur ESO gekommen.
Ja, ich habe in Deutschland meistens studiert, dann habe ich in Australien promoviert,
dann habe ich in Schottland gearbeitet eine Weile und dann bin ich zur ESO gekommen.
Und hast du dann geplant oder gebaut?
Da habe ich zuerst nur geforscht ein paar Jahre lang und dann bin ich zu dem
Team gestoßen, das die wissenschaftliche Planung für die nächste Generation an Teleskopen macht,
für das sogenannte ELT, das Extremely Large Telescope.
Das scheint ja auch so ein Ding zu sein. Ich habe auch gesehen,
es gab auch, also erstmal die Abkürzung.
Das ist leider...
Das, was ich gesehen habe, war irgendwann mal eine Planung, ein OUL zu bauen,
ein OWL, das Overwhelmingly Large Telescope. Da haben sie es doch echt übertrieben, oder?
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Das war ein super Akronym. Das war eine super Abkürzung.
Weil AUL, Eule, hat große Augen.
Warum baut man das dann nicht auch gleich?
Ja, das...
Ist egal, wie man es nennt.
Ja, genau. Nein, also das ist leider tatsächlich so, obwohl Astronomen in der
Regel recht kreativ sind, weil wenn es um die Teleskopnamen sind,
dann geht es so mit der Kreativität.
Das hat aber auch den Grund, dass eben wir, also oft werden ja Teleskope dann
nach berühmten Astronomen benannt.
Stichwort Hubble-Weltraumteleskop zum Beispiel. Das ist natürlich,
aber wenn man eine europäische Organisation ist, dann hat das die Schwierigkeit,
wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel das Kepler-Teleskop habe oder so,
was es ja auch gibt im Übrigen, das ist ein NASA-Weltraumteleskop.
Wenn ich zum Beispiel ein Teleskop nach Kepler soll.
Dann sagen, oh ja, guck mal, das war ja ein Pole und dann schreien die an.
Also das ist das Problem. Deswegen haben wir diese langweiligen Namen.
Also wir haben das Very Large Telescope, jetzt werden wir das Extremely Large
Telescope bekommen. und das Overwhelmingly Large Telescope, das war eine Konzeptstudie,
die wir hatten für ein 100 Meter großes Telescope.
Und das war eine tolle Studie, war aber wie gesagt nur eine Konzeptstudie.
Und es gab sogar technisch gesehen,
das wäre nicht einfach gewesen, so etwas zu bauen, aber technisch gesehen gab
es zumindest bis zu dem Punkt, in dem man das studiert hat, gar nicht so,
Also war es nicht wirklich unmöglich, aber es wäre halt sehr, sehr teuer gewesen.
Also das hätte eben Gelder gekostet, die die Möglichkeiten der ESO eben überstiegen hätten.
Und dann wurde eben entschieden, backen wir mal etwas kleinere Brötchen,
gucken wir mal so, beschränken wir uns auf den Bereich 30 bis 60 Meter.
Herausgekommen war dann eine Studie oder war dann Planung für ein 42 Meter großes Teleskop. 42?
Ja.
Die Audiences wissen nicht.
War das aber, der Politik war das dann doch noch ein Tuck zu teuer,
sodass wir dann nochmal ein ganz kleines bisschen...
Vielleicht war der Name nicht gut.
Ja, daran lag es nicht.
Naja, also gutes Branding. Wie wäre es mit super kalifragilistisch,
expialigetisches Super-Teleskop oder so?
Doofe Abkürzung. Aber ja, dann wurde rausgekommen schließlich ein 39,3 Meter
großes Teleskop, das wir dann...
Wenn man das umrechnet auf das englische Längenmaß Yard, dann ist es auch wieder 42 Grad groß.
Ich habe so den Verdacht, das sind alles Science-Fiction-Fans.
Bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei den, also aufs ELT wollte ich gleich noch mal
zu sprechen kommen, aber das gibt es ja auch noch nicht.
Sondern wir befinden uns ja jetzt im Prinzip in der, also erstmal,
wir betrachten ja jetzt im Wesentlichen den Bereich optische Beobachtung des
Weltalls an Stellen, wo man irgendwie durchgucken kann,
weil nicht so viel Wasser ist und man hoch genug ist, dass da nicht die Luft
so viel rumschwappt und man hat auch nicht so viele nervige Menschen drumherum,
die die ganze Zeit irgendwie ihre Handys anmachen, deswegen kann man irgendwie auch nochmal was sehen.
Das ist sozusagen ja so der Fokus. Und man betrachtet im Wesentlichen halt so
das normale Licht und so den Infrarotbereich und also alles,
was sozusagen eigentlich irgendwie durchkommt.
Alles, was die Atmosphäre durchlässt.
Genau, und die Generation von Teleskopen, mit denen wir da heute leben,
das ist so das, was so in den 90ern und so weiter gebaut wurde,
weil das eigentlich erst so der Moment war, wo man, ja weiß ich nicht,
das tun konnte oder bereit war, das zu finanzieren oder?
Oder wo man es technisch tun konnte, ja.
Denn es gab noch einen Griff, wir haben ja vorhin gesprochen,
von dem Schritt von den Refraktoren, also den Linsenteleskopen,
hin zu den Spiegelteleskopen.
Und dann hatte man, als man da war, hatte man diese Spiegel dann versucht,
möglichst groß und dick zu machen, damit sie sich eben, wie gesagt,
nicht unter ihrem eigenen Gewicht zu sehr verformen.
Aber das hatte eben seine Grenzen, weil je größer und dicker ich es mache,
desto schwerer man es macht und desto mehr verformt es sich dann letztendlich.
Und dann kam halt irgendwann der Schritt, kamen dann Technologien auf,
die wurden in den 80er Jahren dann entwickelt, unter anderem eben auch in der
europäischen Südsternwarte, dass man auf den Trichter kam, ich mache mein Teleskop
nicht mehr besonders steif und versuche das klobig zu machen,
dass es sich möglichst überhaupt nicht mehr bewegen kann,
sondern ganz im Gegenteil, ich baue mein Teleskop besonders leicht und lasse
es sich durchaus verformen, aber ich baue überall sogenannte Aktuatoren an,
sozusagen kleine Stempel, mit denen ich das Teleskop,
die Form eines Spiegels verändern kann Und auch die Position von Spiegeln ganz minimal,
wie gesagt, wir sprachen eben von den 10 Nanometern, also ganz minimal die Form
der Spiegel und die relative Position der Spiegel verändern kann.
Und zwar in Echtzeit, das heißt während ich die Beobachtungen mache.
Das heißt, was da vor sich geht, ist, das Teleskop checkt, während man beobachtet
damit, checkt das Teleskop selbst, wie gut die Bildqualität ist,
die das Teleskop gerade liefert.
Und es kann analysieren, was getan werden muss, um diese Bildqualität noch zu verbessern.
Also Autofokus sozusagen.
Ja, sehr genau. Ja, eigentlich gar nicht so falsch. Autofokus.
Das ist so kompliziert erklärt.
Ja, ja, also genau, es sind halt die höheren Ordnungen, die da korrigiert werden
müssen. Autofokus ist eben eine der schwierigen Ordnungen.
Also indem man das Bild selber misst oder gibt es dann irgendwie auch noch Messdaten
aus der Luft? Man weiß irgendwie, heute kommt mal wieder ein bisschen mehr Luft,
da müssen wir ein bisschen drehen.
Nein, nein, es sind tatsächlich Bilddaten an Lust. Das heißt,
man guckt sich die Sterne an, die man sich so guckt. Man hat einen Leitstern
halt, den man sich anguckt.
Und mit dem Leitstern kann ich die Bildqualität eben vermessen.
Und dann kann ich eben, keine Ahnung, einmal pro Minute oder sowas,
kann ich eben dann das Teleskop ganz leicht verformen oder auch die Position
von Spiegeln ganz leicht anpassen, um eben die Bildqualität sozusagen optimal zu halten.
Was sind das für Aktuaturen? Also da drückt dann irgendwas rein?
Im Prinzip ja, aber es drückt etwas und es gibt verschiedene Technologien.
Also im Prinzip zum Beispiel eine Pezo-Technologie, wo man kleine Kristalle hat.
Wenn ich da eine Spannung anlege, dann dehnt sich dieses Kristall ganz leicht
aus und drückt dann eben auf den Spiegel.
Das heißt unter einem 8,2 Meter Spiegel habe ich dann ganz viele solche Stempelsitzen,
die sieht man, wenn man drunter guckt und die können eben den Spiegel ganz leicht verformen in sich.
Das ist die sogenannte aktive Optik. Also ein Teleskop ist heutzutage kein passives
Ding mehr, sondern es ist ein aktives Ding, das die ganze Zeit sozusagen in
Bewegung ist. Wie unser Auge.
Genau. Und diese Technologie war vonnöten, um sozusagen die 6-Meter-Grenze zu
durchbrechen und eben 8 und 10 Meter große Technologie zu bauen.
Weil sonst wäre es einfach unter seinem eigenen Gewicht.
Genau, sonst wäre der Primärspiegel einfach unter seinem eigenen Gewicht,
hätte sich immer verformt. Das hätte man nicht in den Griff kriegen können.
Genau, und erst mit dieser aktiven Technologie ist das möglich geworden.
Aber gab es nicht auch in den 90ern, ich erinnere mich jetzt gerade,
ich streue ja mal gerne Referenzen hier auf alte Sendungen ein,
ich habe ja schon mal eine Sendung gemacht über ROSA, den Röntgenteleskopen,
das Röntgenteleskop im All,
der ja auch erst möglich war durch eine neue Spiegelschleiftechnik,
dass man sozusagen überhaupt diese Spiegel überhaupt erstmal so glatt bekommen
hat, wie wir das heutzutage haben. Spielte das auch noch eine Rolle?
Und zum Teil, ja, weil mit neuen Spiegelschleiftechniken, ja,
man kann sie noch besser, also die Oberfläche noch besser schleifen,
das heißt die übrig gebliebenen Unebenheiten im Spiegel sind heute tatsächlich noch besser als früher,
aber vor allem kann man heute auch kompliziertere Formen in einen Spiegel reinschleifen,
als man das früher konnte.
Das heißt, ich kann eben nicht nur einen Parabolspiegel oder eine Kugel schleifen.
Etwas, was komplett rund ist, das kann man besonders leicht schleifen.
Eine Parabolform ist auch noch relativ leicht zu schleifen. aber in Großteleskopen
hat man aus verschiedenen Gründen möchte man tatsächlich noch andere Formen da reinschleifen.
Einfach weil sonst kriegt man optische Fehler rein in die Bilder.
Achso, ich dachte, so Großmuster oder sowas.
Nee, nee, man kriegt einfach optische Fehler rein in die Bilder.
Und das möchte man nicht haben.
Und dann braucht man eben kompliziertere optisches Design und dafür muss ich
dann eben die Spiegel tatsächlich etwas anders schleifen.
Und das war in der Tat früher nicht möglich. Das kann man auch erst heute.
Warum kann man das jetzt erst, weil man jetzt noch mit Laser dabei geht und das besser messen kann?
Durch Computertechnologie, also eine bessere Technologie, die Schleif-Technologie,
also die Schleif-Instrumente besser,
das dauert ja auch ewig, so ein Schliff, das ist ja nicht so,
was mal eben über Nacht gemacht wird, das dauert ewig, so einen Spiegel einzuschleifen,
aber eben auch die Technologie, mit der ich das ja überprüfe.
Ich muss ja auch überprüfen können, ob ich denn das, was meine Schleifmaschine
gemacht hat, ob das ja auch tatsächlich richtig gemacht hat,
das muss ich ja auch überprüfen können. Das machen wir mit so Interferometern
und das musste man auch erstmal alles in den Griff kriegen.
Verstehe. Okay, also Spiegel ging besser zu schleifen, besser zu bauen und man
war in der Lage, welche zu bauen, die sich quasi wie so eine Netzhaut,
schlechter Vergleich, aber die adaptiv sind. Ja, aktiv.
Adaptiv ist immer was anderes.
Ja, aber sie reagieren, also okay.
Wie aktiv sind, die man eben drücken kann, das war eben der Grund.
Die reagieren sozusagen.
Genau, und das ist eben der Grund, warum diese Spiegel jetzt auch relativ dünn sein müssen.
Also ich sprach eben davon, so ein 8,2 Meter Spiegel ist nur 20 Zentimeter dick,
weil sehr viel dicker da war eben nicht sein, weil dann kriege ich ein Problem,
dann kriege ich ihn nicht mehr gedrückt.
Weil ich ja von hinten drücken muss und vor ohne die Oberfläche ändern muss.
Nur ist ja gut, 20 Zentimeter dicker Spiegel hängt man sich jetzt mal nicht ins Wohnzimmer.
Nee, nee, deswegen sagte ich eben, das ist kein Badezimmerspiegel.
Warum ist er denn überhaupt so dick? Damit er insgesamt strukturell überhaupt hält. Genau.
Ich muss ihn ja irgendwie aufhängen können erstmal.
Ja, okay.
Genau, das waren Dinge, die man machen, die man eben alle technologisch in den
Griff kriegen musste, bevor man eben diese Großteleskope, die wir heute eben
haben, in Angriff nehmen konnte.
Gut, dann nehmen wir jetzt nochmal das Beispiel raus, was wir schon ein paar
Mal angesprochen haben.
Also das VLT, Very Large Telescope von der ESO in der Atacama-Wüste, ist ein fettes Ding.
Gehört glaube ich jetzt immer noch zu den Größen oder ist sogar das?
Das ist nicht das größte.
Das gerade rumsteht. Einzel genommen ist, also das VLT besteht aus vier Teleskopen, wie gesagt.
Und jedes davon ist 8,2 Meter. Und einzeln, für sich genommen,
sind es nicht die größten. Wie gesagt, wir haben 10,4 Meter große Teleskope.
Aber zusammengenommen, alle vier zusammen, sind natürlich eines der schlagkräftigsten
astronomischen Instrumente, die wir haben.
Und wir reden davon von vier separaten Gebäuden.
Es sind vier separate Gebäude, genau.
Die stehen?
Und die stehen in einem Abstand von mehreren zehn Metern. Der größte Abstand
zwischen zwei ist, glaube ich, knapp 200 Meter.
Und man kann diese Teleskope tatsächlich auch zusammenschalten.
Das nennt man Interferometrie. Das macht man in der Radioastronomie schon sehr lange.
In der Infrarotastronomie ist das aber sehr, sehr viel schwieriger.
Deswegen hat das sehr viel länger gedauert, das hinzukriegen.
Aber das geht mittlerweile. Man kann tatsächlich alle vier Spiegel des VLT zusammenschalten
und wie ein Instrument, wie ein Teleskop betreiben, das geht.
Und das wird aber nur manchmal gemacht?
Das wird nur manchmal gemacht, weil man natürlich alle vier Teleskope blockiert damit.
Das hängt damit zusammen, dass ich, wenn ich alle vier miteinander zusammenschalte,
dann kann ich nicht sehr lange belichten.
Weil ich, wenn ich das Licht dieser vier Teleskope zusammenschalte, das passiert kohärent.
Das heißt, das Licht wird nicht einfach irgendwie auf den Detektor projiziert,
sondern das wird zusammengeführt, sodass die Phase des Lichts,
also Licht ist ja eine Welle und hat eine Phase und diese Phase muss genau richtig
übereinander gelegt werden.
Das heißt, die Laufzeitunterschiede des Lichts der einzelnen Teleskope müssen
ausgeglichen werden und zwar auf den Bruchteil einer Wellenlänge genau ausgeglichen
werden. Und das ist eine sehr, sehr schwierige Technologie.
Und das aufrecht zu erhalten, ist schwierig.
Und das kann man eben nicht beliebig lange aufrecht erhalten,
dieses kohärente Überlagern des Lichts. Und deswegen kann man nicht sehr lange belichten.
Und außerdem funktioniert das Ganze bisher auch nur im infraroten und noch nicht
im optischen Licht, weil das ist noch schwieriger.
Okay, also wir haben da diese vier Dinger stehen und jetzt ignorieren wir mal,
dass es vier sind, sondern schauen wir es einfach nur bei dem Betrieb vom Einzelner ab.
Weil das, was ich noch nicht so ganz verstanden habe, ist, okay,
man hat da jetzt so ein Häuschen, da ist irgendwie Deckel drauf,
dann wird es nacht und man macht Deckel auf.
Richtig, nicht nur die Deckel, man macht auch überall die Klappen auf.
Die Klappen?
Ja, man möchte schön Windfluss durch das Teleskop haben.
Wegen Kühlung?
Ja, wegen, ich möchte einen schönen laminaren Fluss über meinen Hauptspiegel
haben, damit es da keine Turbulenzen gibt.
Und ich möchte drinnen genau die gleiche Temperatur haben wie draußen.
Denn ansonsten hätte ich aufsteigende Luft und sprich Turbulenzen,
schlecht für die Bildqualität.
Deswegen wird schon tagsüber das Gebäude klimatisiert auf die Temperatur,
die ich am Abend erwarte.
Tagsüber läuft da ja gar nichts, ne?
Oh, doch.
Also da wird da repariert und gemacht und getroffen und getroffen.
Genau, da wird gewartet und es wird kalibriert. Also das Teleskop wird zum Teil
auch benutzt und da ist es auch dunkel da drin, weil man eben die Aufnahmen,
die nachts gemacht wurden, dazu braucht man noch zusätzliche Aufnahmen, um das Kalibrieren.
Und diese Kalibrationsaufnahmen, die werden zum Teil tagsüber gemacht.
Also man macht sozusagen ein Gegenfoto im Dunkeln, um zu gucken,
wie sich das von dem anderen Dunkeln unterscheidet.
Ja, also ein Beispiel, wenn ich ein Spektrum aufnehme, also ich nehme einen
Stern und nehme das Licht, breche es auf als Funktion der Wellenlänge,
Dann habe ich das Spektrum auf meinem Detektor.
Jetzt weiß ich aber noch nicht, welche Pixel auf meinem Detektor welcher Wellenlänge entspricht.
Dafür brauche ich jetzt noch eine Aufnahme von einer Lampe, die eben Linien
hat bei bestimmten Wellenlängen, die ich kenne.
Aber diese Aufnahme kann ich auch tagsüber machen. Das muss ich nicht nachts machen.
Okay, verstehe. Aber wenn es dunkel ist, dann wird das Teleskop vollständig
in seiner Umgebung aufzugehen.
Temperatur, Wind, alles ist eins, außer der Null.
Und ich habe gehört, dass dann auch irgendwie alle ihre Fenster zumachen müssen.
Stimmt das?
Also es sind natürlich alle Gebäude, die es dort gibt. An den Observatorien
gibt es ja nicht nur die Teleskope, sondern auch andere Gebäude.
Da leben ja zu dem gegebenen Zeitpunkt, halten sich da gut 100 Menschen auf.
Die wollen auch abends was essen und auch nachts nochmal was essen und die gehen
nachts mal aufs Klo und so.
Und klar, da muss man natürlich dafür sorgen, dass wenn die aufs Klo gehen und
das Licht im Badezimmer machen, dass dann nicht das ganze Licht schön nach draußen scheint.
Das stimmt.
Das heißt, da wird überall zugemacht. Alle Fenster werden bei Sonnenuntergang
dicht gemacht, lichtdicht zugemacht, dass da tatsächlich nichts rauskommt.
Das heißt, wenn man da nachts rumläuft, dunkler wird es nicht mehr. Richtig.
Okay, so, jetzt Klappe auf. Wir sind irgendwie eingepasst. Der laminale Flow
stimmt. Das gefällt mir sehr gut.
Genau.
Gedanke allein. So, und jetzt trifft Licht auf den Spiegel.
Wenn wir uns gerade irgendwas Tolles anschauen, wo geht es hin?
Das Licht kommt von außen, trifft auf den Hauptspiegel. Das hängt jetzt natürlich
vom einzelnen Teleskop ab, aber bleiben wir mal jetzt beim VLT.
Es gibt unterschiedliche Designs, aber bleiben wir beim VLT.
Das trifft auf den Hauptspiegel.
Von dem Hauptspiegel geht es auf den Sekundärspiegel, der eben hier oben hängt,
und von dem Sekundärspiegel.
Jetzt haben wir schon die Wahl. Entweder lassen wir das Licht durch ein Loch
im Hauptspiegel direkt in ein Instrument, das unter dem Hauptspiegel angebracht
ist, im sogenannten Kasselgran-Fokus, lasst das Licht in dieses Instrument laufen.
Oder ich habe noch einen dritten Spiegel über dem Hauptspiegel sitzen,
der das Licht seitwärts entweder nach links oder nach rechts rausschickt auf eine große Plattform.
Also rechts und links hat das Telescope jeweils eine große Plattform,
den sogenannten Naismith-Fokus.
Und dort stehen eben meine Instrumente, die dann das Licht aufnehmen.
Das heißt, mit Instrumenten meinen wir also Kameras oder Spektrografen oder
dergleichen, die dann das Licht tatsächlich aufnehmen, noch weiterverarbeiten
und dann letztendlich auf einem irgendwie gearteten Detektor festhalten.
Können die Instrumente parallel arbeiten oder muss man sich da sozusagen entscheiden, was man beobachtet?
Man muss sich in der Regel entscheiden, es gibt Beispiele, auf dem Hubble-Weltraumteleskop
ist es zum Beispiel auch möglich, Instrumente parallel gleichzeitig zu benutzen,
aber am VLT muss man sich für ein Instrument entscheiden.
Okay, das heißt, erstmal zählt die Methode quasi und die hängt davon ab, was man beobachtet.
Was möchte ich machen? Will ich ein Bild nehmen? Wenn ja, in welchem Wellenlängenbereich?
Im optischen, im Infraroten, im Ferninfraroten?
Will ich lieber Spektren aufnehmen? Wenn ja, bei welcher spektralen Auflösung?
Pipapo, also da gibt es viele verschiedene Möglichkeiten. nehmen.
Okay, und wenn jetzt Alarm im Weltall ist, weil Supernova wurde detektiert,
es gibt ja, du hast ja vorhin schon angesprochen, diese Durchmusterung,
Teleskope, die sind ja dazu da, nicht etwas zu beobachten, sondern möglichst alles.
Das sind so ein bisschen die Wachhunde, die so rumstehen und sagen so,
da an der Ecke, da hat sich gerade etwas verändert,
alle mal herhören und dann wird das rote Telefon in die Hand genommen und alle
fangen an, Also bei einer Supernova oder so, da geht es doch weltweit ab wie
Schmitzkatze, oder? Also da sind doch irgendwie alle dabei.
Nö.
Ist nicht so.
So eine einzelne Supernova ist jetzt auch nicht mehr so spannend.
Supernova.
Langweilig.
Kommt drauf an, wo sie ist und wie war. Aber ja, eine Supernova in unserer eigenen
Galaxie, das wäre eine andere.
Ja, okay, gut.
Also das wäre, ja, dann wäre Alarm. Oder nehmen wir doch mal ein Beispiel, das wir gerade hatten.
Da wollte ich jetzt am Ende noch mal drauf kommen.
Supernova in unserer Galaxie ist jetzt selten. Was weiß ich,
alle 90, 100 Jahre, 150, keine Ahnung.
Alle mehrere hundert Jahre.
Mehrere hundert Jahre. Aber es steht mal wieder eine an, glaube ich.
Es wäre schön, wenn mal eine käme. Es dürfte jetzt nicht zu nah sein,
aber es wäre schön, wenn mal eine in der Umgebung los wäre. Das Schönste,
was wir hatten, war 1987.
Das war das Höchste der Gefühle in dieser Gedanken, eine Supernova in der...
Was in der kleinen oder großen Magellanschen Wolke, die unsere am nächsten gelegene
Zwerggalaxie ist, da ging halt eine ab und ja, das war das höchste der Gefühle bisher.
Okay, da waren die ganzen Teleskope ja noch nicht da. Was würde jetzt passieren,
wenn jetzt in der Andromeda-Galaxie, also quasi um die Ecke, was los schießt?
Ja, es gibt tatsächlich einigen Observatorien, die können das tatsächlich,
die können sehr schnell reagieren.
Am VLT ist das tatsächlich der Fall. Da gibt es den sogenannten Rapid Response Mode.
Da kann also, wenn da getriggert wird, also wenn da eine Beobachtung ausgelöst
wird in diesem Modus, dann lässt das Teleskop quasi alles stehen und liegen, was es gerade tut.
Es liest die Aufnahme, die gerade gemacht wird, wird nicht mal ausgelesen.
Das heißt, es wird einfach nur abgebrochen.
Und dann schwingt das Teleskop auf diesen Punkt, auf den es eben hin soll und
fängt sofort an aufzunehmen.
Also das heißt, man kann von dem Trigger bis zur Aufnahme vergehen.
Das hängt jetzt davon ab, wie weit das Teleskop sich bewegen muss und so weiter.
Aber vergehen unter Umständen nur zwei Minuten oder so.
Und von den 100 Wissenschaftlern sind 99 total begeistert und der eine,
dessen Experiment gerade abgebrochen wurde. drei Monate drauf gewartet hat, der ist frustriert.
Genau.
Okay, und welches Instrument würde man dann nehmen?
Dass das gerade dran ist. Dass das gerade benutzt wird, weil um zu switchen
auf andere Instrumente dauert einige Minuten, hängt wiederum davon ab,
aber das kann unter Umständen einige Minuten dauern, weil das Instrument erstmal
hochgefahren werden muss,
muss vom Standby erstmal in den On-Modus gebracht werden, es muss womöglich
der ZZR-Spiegel, der dritte Spiegel muss gedreht werden oder aus dem Weg gefahren
werden, das dauert halt alles und das Das will man dann gar nicht machen,
sondern man nimmt dann das Instrument, das gerade dran ist.
Okay, und wenn man es vorher wüsste?
Wenn man was vorher wüsste?
Ja, aber dass es gleich eine Supernova ist.
Ja, dann bräuchte ich den Rapid-Response-Mode nicht. Dann könnte man sich natürlich
wunderbar darauf vorbereiten.
Ja, ich meine, welches Instrument würde man dann nehmen? Dann würden sich wahrscheinlich
alle abstimmen und sagen, du nimmst das, du nimmst das, du nimmst das.
Das kommt drauf an. Um das zu relativieren, Supernovae sind mittlerweile mit
so ziemlich allen Instrumenten beobachtet worden, die man kann.
Aber wenn man jetzt wüsste, dass hier in der Galaxie eine Supernova übermorgen
anstünde, dann würde man alles auffahren, was man hat.
Also dann würde man sich nicht versuchen, für irgendwas zu entscheiden,
sondern man würde tatsächlich mit allem drauf gucken, was man hat.
Okay, also ich bin mit meiner Strategie gerade so ein bisschen gescheitert,
irgendwie so einen Instrumentenauswahlvorgang nachzuvollziehen.
Hängt dann im Wesentlichen von der wissenschaftlichen Untersuchung ab,
die dann halt gemacht werden soll. Aber was wäre jetzt so der Klassiker?
Also das Erste, womit man immer anfängt, ist natürlich, wenn man irgendein neues
Phänomen hat, ist das Erste, dass man Bildaufnahmen macht, und so guckt,
kann man irgendwas aufgelöst sehen oder es ist tatsächlich nur eine Punktquelle.
Man misst die Helligkeiten dann bei verschiedenen Wellenlängen durch das ganze
Optische durch, durch das ganze UV oder vom UV bis zum Infraroten,
halt alles, was man vom Boden aus machen kann.
Und dann, je nachdem wie hell das Objekt ist, wenn es hell genug ist,
dann fange ich an Spektroskopie zu betreiben als nächstes und versuche tatsächlich das Licht zu zerlegen.
Wie hell ist das Licht als Funktion der Wellenlänge? Da sieht man dann eben
Absorptionslinien oder Emissionslinien oder ein Kontinuum.
Weil erst mit der Spektroskopie kann ich so richtig Physik betreiben.
Dann kann ich wirklich versuchen zu verstehen, was bei diesem Phänomen oder
Objekt oder was auch immer ich mir da angucke, tatsächlich passiert.
Weil man es dann auf Elemente runterbrechen kann und sagen kann, hier Kohlenstoff hat.
Ja, genau, weil ich Bewegung sehen kann, weil ich Elemente bis ich chemische
Zusammensetzung sehen kann, weil ich eben Bewegung sehen kann,
weil ich Dynamik sehen kann, all solche Dinge. Also generell sagt man immer
gerne, erst als die Spektroskopie erfunden wurde, ist aus der Astronomie Astrophysik geworden.
Und wenn man das alles gemacht hat, dann macht man das immer feiner,
dann kann man versuchen, die irgendwelche zeitlichen Veränderungen aufzunehmen.
Also dann versucht man das jede Nacht zu beobachten oder zumindest einmal die
Woche zu beobachten, um zeitliche Veränderungen womöglich wahrzunehmen und da
dann mit immer noch hochauflöseren Spektren.
Also da sind der Fantasie keine Grenzen gesetzt.
Aber welchen Grenzen sind denn jetzt diesen Teleskopen gesetzt?
Also wenn man jetzt schon so ein Very Large Telescope haben will,
wo ist denn da jetzt das Ende?
Warum brauchte man auf einmal ein Extremely Large Telescope oder sogar kein
Overwhelmingly Large Telescope?
Ja, gute Frage. Warum wollen Astronomen größere Teleskope haben?
Weil, das ist ganz einfach, weil es hat zwei Gründe. Je größer mein Teleskop,
desto größer ist die Lichtsammelfläche und desto mehr Licht pro Zeiteinheit kann ich einsammeln.
Das bedeutet, für eine gegebene Beobachtungszeit kann ich lichtschwächere Objekte sehen.
Lichtschwächere Objekte bedeutet entweder, ich kann dasselbe Objekt zu größerer
Entfernung sehen oder eben intrinsisch lichtschwächere Objekte bei der gleichen Entfernung sehen.
Also ich kann entweder noch lichtschwächere, kleinere Sterne sehen bei einer
bekannten Entfernung oder ich kann eben eine Galaxie zu noch größeren Distanzen sehen.
Das ist natürlich immer von Interesse für Astronomien, wir wollen möglichst
weit raus sehen und wollen möglichst die gesamte Population an Objekten sehen,
die da draußen ist, nicht nur die hellsten Beispiele einer Population von Galaxien
oder von Sternen, nicht nur immer die hellsten Beispiele sehen,
sondern eben auch die kleineren, lichtschwächeren Objekte sehen.
Hat das auch einen Einfluss auf den Ausschnitt, also den Bereich,
den man beobachten kann?
Das hat auch einen Einfluss daraus.
Je größer das Teleskop, desto schwieriger oder im Prinzip desto kleiner wird das Gesichtsfeld.
Ein großes Gesichtsfeld für ein großes Teleskop zu bauen, ist schwierig oder ist schwieriger.
Aber die Lichtsammelkapazität, das ist das eine. Und das andere ist die Auflösung,
also die Schärfe der Bilder, die ich mit einem Teleskop machen kann,
hängt fundamental mit der Größe des Teleskops zusammen.
Je größer mein Teleskop ist, desto schärfer sind die Bilder,
die ich damit machen kann. Vielen Dank.
Aber Achtung, wir hatten ja eben, wir haben schon von der Atmosphäre gesprochen,
die Erdatmosphäre verschmiert die Bilder.
Tatsächlich ist es so, dass es bei einem 8 Meter Teleskop, das wir heute schon
haben, ist die Schärfe der Bilder zunächst einmal limitiert,
wenn ich nichts mache, ist die Schärfe der Bilder nicht durch die Größe des
Teleskops limitiert, sondern durch die Atmosphäre limitiert.
Das heißt, wenn die Atmosphäre nicht wäre, dann wären die Bilder,
die ich mit meinem 8-Meter-Teleskop machen kann, sehr viel schärfer,
als sie tatsächlich sind.
Warum ist das überhaupt von Interesse? Naja, Schärfe der Bilder ist schon von Interesse.
Denn je schärfer ein Bild ist, desto leichter kann ich zum Beispiel zwei Objekte,
die am Himmel sehr nah stehen, voneinander trennen.
Doppelsterne zum Beispiel.
Doppelsterne oder noch interessanter, ein Exoplanet zum Beispiel.
Ein Planet, der seinen Mutterstern umkreist.
Die sind in der Regel nicht sehr weit voneinander entfernt. Und wenn ich die
eben von einer großen Entfernung aus sehe, von ein paar Lichtjahren aus sehe,
dann erscheint eben so ein Exoplanet sehr, sehr nah an seinen Mutterstern von der Erde aus gesehen.
Wenn ich das auflösen will, dann brauche ich eine große Bildschärfe.
Oder eben auch, wenn ich eine Galaxie sozusagen aufsehen will.
Also Sterne sind ja im Prinzip nur Punktquellen, da gibt es nichts aufzulösen,
aber wenn ich eine Galaxie habe, dann möchte ich eben die Struktur einer solchen
Galaxie erkennen können.
Ich möchte Spiralarme sehen, ich möchte Sternentstehungsregionen aufnehmen können
und so weiter und so fort.
Das heißt, Auflösung ist eben auch von großer Bedeutung eben für die Astronomie.
Bigger is better.
Bigger is better, genau. Jetzt ist natürlich, das habe ich ja gesagt,
eben wie gesagt, die Atmosphäre limitiert uns schon.
Ja, wenn das so ist, dann stellt man sich natürlich sofort die Frage,
naja, wenn ich schon mit einem 8-Meter-Teleskop nicht so richtig die Schärfe
dieses Teleskops so richtig ausschöpfen kann, warum baue ich denn dann noch größere Teleskope?
Und der Grund dafür ist, dass es eben mittlerweile eine Technologie,
wir sprachen eben von der aktiven Optik, und mittlerweile haben wir eine Technologie
entwickelt, die sich die adaptive Optik nennt, mit der ich nämlich die Atmosphäre
quasi ausschalten kann.
Also ich kann dieses Verschmieren der Atmosphäre, das die Atmosphäre erzeugt,
weg machen. Also dieses Verschmieren, das kennen wir ja.
Ah, das heißt, die Verschwörungstheoretiker haben doch recht.
Ja, ja, genau. Dieses Verschmieren, das kann man mit bloßem Auge tatsächlich wahrnehmen.
Wenn man irgendwie auf der Straße steht und in die Sterne guckt,
dann funkeln die Sterne. Das kennt jeder, Sterne funkeln.
Ja, aber die Sterne selbst funkeln natürlich nicht. Das Funkeln hat mit den
Sternen ja gar nichts zu tun.
Dieses Funkeln ist genau diese Unschärfe, die durch die Erdatmosphäre hervorgerufen wird.
Und dieses Funkeln kommt daher, dass eben das Bild eines Sterns so ganz leicht
hin und her tanzt und sehr schnell ganz leicht hin- und hertanzt.
Das nehmen wir eben im Auge als Funkeln wahr und wenn man eben lange belichtet
so einen Stern, dann sehe ich eben so eine verschmierte Sternenscheibe statt
eben nur einen gestochen scharfen Punkt.
Und der Witz ist eben, dass ich dieses Hin- und Hertanzen analysieren kann,
wiederum in Echtzeit während einer Beobachtung vonstatten geht,
kann ich das eben analysieren und kann daraus schließen, welche Turbulenzen
es gerade in der Atmosphäre gibt.
Und jetzt kann ich sozusagen, die Gegenmaßnahme ist, dass ich jetzt wieder irgendwo
einen Spiegel in meinem Teleskop oder in meinem Instrument habe und diesen Spiegel jetzt wieder verforme,
und zwar genau so verforme, dass die Verzerrungen, die durch die Erdatmosphäre
hervorgerufen werden, wieder genau rückgängig gemacht werden.
Also ich habe sozusagen das optische Spiegelbild, diese Verzerrungen,
die werden wieder genau ausgeglichen durch meinen etwas welligen Spiegel.
Also wenn man sowas im Schwimmbad hätte, dann könnte man oben auch alles klar
sehen, obwohl Wellen da sind.
Das heißt, aus diesem leicht verschmierten Bild wird auf einmal ein gestochen
scharfes Bild, als ob es die Erd-Atmosphäre gar nicht geben würde.
Das ist nicht nur Software, sondern eine aktive Anpassung des Spiegels.
Genau, das hat mit Software gar nichts zu tun. Das ist kein Post-Processing,
was ich hinterher mache, sondern es passiert, während die Beobachtungen stattfinden.
Und es ist wirklich sehr beeindruckend, wenn man das sieht.
Die adaptive Optik ist ausgeschaltet. Ich gucke mir einen Stern an.
So eine dicke Scheibe und dann drückt man auf den Knopf, man schaltet die adaptive
Optik quasi ein, bei einem guten System geht das dann sehr schnell und dann zippt.
Schnurrt das Bild in sich zusammen und auf einmal habe ich ein super scharfes Bild.
Das ist wie bei Playtron, wo man dann beliebig alte Fotos beliebig weit reinzoomen kann.
Genau, so ungefähr.
Klack, klack, klack, klack, wird es dann immer schärfer.
Genau, so ungefähr. Also das ist eine extrem starke Technologie,
die im Übrigen auch anderswo eingesetzt wird.
Wer seine Augen schon mal gelasert gekriegt hat, da wird auch die adaptive Optik eingesetzt.
Der Unterschied zwischen der adaptiven und der aktiven Optik liegt in der Zeitskala.
Dieses Verformen des Spiegels, um das Bild zu korrigieren, bei der aktiven Optik
findet das einmal die Minute statt oder sogar nur einmal mehrere Minuten.
Bei der adaptiven Optik findet das mehrere hundert Mal pro Sekunde statt,
bis zu tausend Mal pro Sekunde.
Denn das ist die Zeitskala, auf der sich die Atmosphäre bewegt und die Zeitskala,
auf der sich die Sterne hin und her tanzen.
Aber diese Aktuatoren sind jetzt gar nicht anders. Sie werden so anders angestellt.
Genau, so anders sind die gar nicht, die sind ganz ähnlich.
Könnte man dann nicht einfach die alten umbauen, dann hätte man dasselbe in grün?
Ja, im Prinzip schon, nur ich brauche, muss die Dichte der Aktuatoren auf meinem
Spiegel ein bisschen höher sein. Also ich brauche mehr von solchen Aktuatoren.
Okay, also im Prinzip, man hat gesehen, die Technik ist eigentlich total knorke
und wir kriegen sie jetzt sogar noch besser gebaut, also bauen wir noch mehr von den Dingern rein.
Und by the way, wenn wir sowieso schon mal dabei sind, machen wir auch noch
den Spiegel größer, dann haben wir sozusagen win, win, win.
Ja, genau, so ungefähr, Weil nur dann macht es Sinn, nur wenn ich diese Technologie
eben beherrsche, macht es tatsächlich Sinn, noch größere Spiegel zu bauen,
weil sonst hätte ich nur den Effekt, dass ich eben mehr Lichtsammelkapazität habe, ist auch schön,
aber ich möchte eben auch diese erhöhte Auflösung haben.
Ja, also mit Soße und Scharf, genau.
Wie groß ist jetzt Extremely Large?
Ja, Extremely Large sind 39,3 Meter Durchmesser.
Das ist größer als dieses Planetarium, was jetzt die Hörer nicht sehen können.
Aber hier sind es, glaube ich, so 30.
Ja, der Hauptspiegel.
Das ist ganz groß.
Wir haben uns mal den Spaß gemacht. Also jetzt muss man dazu sagen,
ich kann einen Hauptspiegel von der Größe von 39 Metern, das kann ich nicht
mehr aus einem Stück bauen.
Also dieser Spiegel besteht nicht aus einem Stück, sondern er besteht aus sehr
vielen Einzelteilen, sogenannten Segmenten.
Diese Segmente sind sechseckig und die sind etwa gut 1,40 Meter groß.
Und davon braucht man fast 800, um den Hauptspiegel zusammenzusetzen. 798, um genau zu sein.
Aus 798 einzelnen Elementen, die werden dann alle einzelnen aufgehängt an 27 Punkten.
Ich kann jedes einzelne Segment hoch runterfahren, verschieben,
kippen um zwei Achsen und eben auch in sich verformen.
Und das muss ich alles können, weil ja alle 798 Segmente, die ich genau so einstellen
muss, dass sie alle zusammen genau die gewünschte Oberfläche geben,
die der Hauptspiegel eben haben soll.
Wie viel Hub kann denn sozusagen maximal erzeugt werden?
Weil wenn die sich alle so passgenau anpassen müssen, dann muss ja ganz schön
viel Weg gegangen werden.
Ja, also man muss, da gibt es natürlich verschiedene Teile, die den Hub machen.
Ich muss so ein Segment tatsächlich komplett rausschieben können,
weil man so ein Segment auch mal austauschen können muss.
Und dafür muss ich es tatsächlich so ein Stück über die Spiegeloberfläche herausschieben
können, also mehrere Zentimeter rausschieben können, damit dann von oben ein
Kran kommen kann, das Ding anheben kann.
Aber im normalen Betrieb sind das, reden wir hier von Nanometern wiederum,
also von winzigen Teilen.
Ein Nanometer sind 10 hoch minus 9 Meter.
Sehr wenig.
Sehr wenig, genau. Das heißt so, jetzt habe ich also diese 798 Segmente,
die mir also einen Spiegel ergeben und um sich mal eine Vorstellung davon zu
machen zu können, wie groß das ist, haben wir uns mal 798,
Pappelemente ausgeschnitten in der Form, in dieser Hexagonalform und haben die
dann mal auf der Wiese hinter der ESEO mal ausgelegt,
die 798, genau in der Anordnung, wie sie dann auch in dem Spiegel im ELT zugekommen
sollen und das hat großen Spaß gemacht.
Das haben wir irgendwo bestellt, das weiß ich nicht mehr genau.
Aber ja, dafür darf ich jetzt wieder nicht sagen, wahrscheinlich weil wir am
Podcast sind, aber hier sieht man eben ein.
Hier sieht man ein, künftige Veranstaltungen.
Hier sieht man ein, so ein Segment halt, ein, so ein Spiegelsegment,
das ist 5 cm dick, wie gesagt, etwa 1,42 Meter groß und es sieht jetzt nicht
aus wie ein Spiegel, weil es eben noch nicht beschichtet ist,
Also was man da sieht, ist eine spezielle Glaskeramik, die eben die schöne Eigenschaft
hat, dass sie sich eben nicht ausdehnt unter Temperaturveränderungen,
sich eben überhaupt nicht bewegt unter Temperaturveränderungen.
Es sind ganz besondere Glaskeramiken.
Das heißt, sie können nur durch diese mechanischen Aktuatoren beeinflussen?
Genau, nur dadurch werden sie bewegt. Und davon eben werden wir 798 nebeneinander setzen.
Wow, und dann hat man so einen Riesenspiegel, der irgendwie durch,
dem dann die Atmosphäre sozusagen auch überhaupt nichts mehr anhaben kann,
weil es einfach alles in Echtzeit rausgerechnet wird.
Ja, wobei diese Echtzeit, diese adaptive Optik, das findet nicht am Primärspiegel
statt, sondern an einem der anderen Spiegel in dem System, in dem Teleskop.
Da, wo es dann einmal reflektiert worden ist.
Ja, also im ELT ist es ein bisschen anders als am VLT. Am ELT gibt es einen
zweiten Spiegel, der ist immer noch 4,2 Meter groß, riesengroß.
Dann gibt es einen dritten Spiegel.
Und dann gibt es noch einen vierten und einen fünften Spiegel,
bevor das Licht dann nach draußen geschickt wird.
Und dieser vierte und fünfte Spiegel, die machen diese adaptive Optik.
Also die bewegen sich sehr, sehr, sehr schnell. Die machen diese adaptive Optik.
Ah, verstehe. Ich dachte schon, das ganze Monster wird die ganze Zeit so bewegt.
Nein, das ganze Monster nicht. Aber alle anderen Spiegel bewegen sich auch,
aber eben nicht mit der Frequenz von mehreren hundert Grad.
Okay, aber man hat ja das Licht im Prinzip in dem Moment ja auch schon beisammen.
Und wenn der Spiegel gut ist, geht da auch nicht so viel verloren dabei, oder? Vielen Dank.
Richtig, wenn man ihn vernünftig beschichtet hat und einigermaßen sauber ist,
dann geht nicht so viel von dem Licht verloren, das ist richtig.
Aber dann muss es natürlich immer noch, das Teleskop ist das eine,
da hat man die fünf Reflektionen und dann kommt das Licht in das Instrument
und da hat es auch nochmal diverse optische Elemente,
diverse Linsen und Spiegel, wo es durch muss, da geht schon immer noch ein bisschen Licht verloren.
Also gute Instrumente fangen etwa 30 Prozent von den Photonen,
also von dem Licht, das oben reinfällt, schaffen es bis auf den Detektor dann ungefähr.
Und der Rest geht leider verloren. Also die Effizienz ist noch,
aber es ist sehr schwierig, diese Effizienz noch zu steigern.
Also das ist tatsächlich technisch sehr.
Sehr schwierig. Also warum geht das so viel verloren? Bleibst du im Spiegel hängen?
Ja, also keine Reflektion ist perfekt und keine Linse kann 100 Prozent des Lichtes durchlassen.
Ein Teil davon geht immer verloren.
Auch ein Detektor, so ein Detektor, also jedes Detektor, die wir alle in unseren
Handys haben oder in Digitalkameras haben,
diese Detektoren funktionieren ja im Prinzip so, dass dort, wenn ein Licht einfällt
in so einen Pixel, dann wird irgendwie ein Elektron in irgendeiner Form bewegt.
Und das funktioniert eben auch nicht mit perfekter Effizienz.
Wobei die heutigen Detektoren tatsächlich sehr, sehr gut sind.
Das ist eigentlich kaum noch zu steigern. Also die sind fast an 100 Prozent dran.
Die liegen alle so bei 98 Prozent. Aber eben bei diesen ganzen anderen optischen
Elementen, da geht immer noch was verloren.
Nimm den Hauptspiegel. Der Hauptspiegel ist ja, wie gesagt, wir sind draußen in der Wüste.
Der ist ja offen. Wir sind da nicht in einem schönen Labor, das ich irgendwie
schön sauber halten kann. Wir sind da in der Wüste, da geht ein Wind,
da fällt Staub drauf. Da ist Dreck drauf auf so einem Spiegel.
Und jedes Staubkörnchen streut das einkommende Licht und streut es und schickt
es nicht dahin, wo das hin sollte, sondern dieses Licht ist verloren.
Also das kann nie perfekt sein.
Und man muss, man könnte doch das Ganze noch filtern, Staub filtern,
aber dann hat man nicht mehr den laminaren Flow.
Ja, natürlich versuche ich das innen drin.
Natürlich mache ich, deswegen macht man tagsüber ja auch so eine,
deswegen baue ich überhaupt eine Kuppel um so ein Teleskop rum und mache es tagsüber zu.
Ja gut, aber wenn ich alle Klappen aufmache, um mich da irgendwie einzublenden,
dann öffne ich ja sozusagen dem Staub, Tür und Tor im wahrsten Sinne.
Klar, weil sonst eben habe ich eben diese Turbulenzen über dem Spiegel,
die mir die Bildqualität zerstören.
Aber was ich natürlich gegen den Staub tun kann, ich kann ja eben ab und zu
Spiegel entweder sauber machen oder was tatsächlich passiert wird,
dass normalerweise eben so ein Hauptspiegel oder nicht nur der Hauptspiegel,
alle Spiegel aus dem Teleskop ab und zu ausgebaut werden und komplett neu beschichtet werden.
Das heißt, dass die dünne Metallschicht, in der Regel ist das Aluminium,
die dünne Metallschicht, die auf der Glaskeramik, die da drauf gedampft wird,
diese Metallschicht hält auch nicht.
Also abgesehen davon, dass sie dreckig wird, korridiert sie eben auch im Laufe
der Zeit und hat also eine endliche Lebensdauer. Und deswegen ab und zu muss ich die runter...
Wird nicht wirklich runtergekratzt, sondern wird chemisch runtergemacht und
dann wird sie neu bedampft.
Also nehmen wir mal so einen, die Schicht ist extrem dünn, nehmen wir mal so
einen 8-Meter-Spiegel von dem VLT,
der wird mit Aluminium bedampft und das Aluminium, das da draufkommt,
also 8-Meter-Spiegel, der hat etwa 50 Quadratmeter und da kommt Aluminium drauf,
das entspricht ungefähr einer der Haushaltsaluminiumfolie, ein DIN A4-Blatt.
Das ist die Menge Aluminium, die auf 50 Quadratmeter verteilt wird.
Wow, das ist nicht viel.
Nein, nicht viel. Es sind noch einige Atomlagen von Aluminium.
Wenn man jetzt, ELT kommt glaube ich 2024 ist so der Plan. First Light.
Genau.
Kommt dann das erste Licht sozusagen in aktive Nutzung.
Was ist denn so die Erwartung, wie gut das Bild dann sein wird?
Ist man dann schon wieder so bei Hubble-Qualitäten oder ist es davon noch fern?
Es ist 15 mal besser als Hubble. Ernsthaft? Ja, ernsthaft.
Weil ja, wie gesagt, die Bildqualität, die Schärfe eines Bildes hängt ja von
der Größe des Teleskops ab.
Und jetzt haben wir ein 39,3 Meter Teleskop. Hubble ist 2,5 Meter groß.
Hubble ist ja ein Winsteleskop. Hubble verdankt seine...
Das ist ja ein Witz.
Ja, klar.
Lächerlich.
Hubble verdankt natürlich seine gute Bildqualität, seine Position oberhalb der
Atmosphäre. dass es eben mit dieser ganzen aktiven Optik gar nichts am Hut haben zu brauchen.
Also es ist da oben, das ist alles wunderbar. Aber wenn ich jetzt eben quasi
die Atmosphäre ausschalten kann, was wir ja auch heute schon mit dem VLT können,
die Bildqualität, die Schärfe der Bilder, die dabei rauskommt,
auch heute schon vom VLT, ist besser als die von Hubble.
Man hat nicht ganz diese Stabilität, die Hubble hat, weil ich eben immer noch diese Atmosphäre habe.
Und die Korrektur ist natürlich nicht konstant immer perfekt gleich gut,
sondern variiert die nach den atmosphärischen Bedingungen.
Also diese tolle Konstanz, die man eben von Hubble hat und auch diese Temperaturkonstanz,
die ja auch Hubble hat, das kriege ich natürlich auf der Erdoberfläche nicht hin.
Aber von der reinen Schärfe der Bilder bin ich mittlerweile auf der Erde besser als Hubble.
Weil ich eben mittlerweile adaptive Optik beherrsche.
Und das James-Webb-Teleskop, das liegt mir davor?
Das James-Webb-Space-Teleskop, das nächstes Jahr gestartet werden soll.
Das ist ein 6-Meter-Teleskop.
Wird nächstes Jahr, kommt übernächstes. Ist verschoben worden.
Ah ja, habe ich noch gar nicht gehört.
Ja, weil die Merkur-Mission Verspätung hat und die können nicht beide gleichzeitig machen.
Ach, guck an, da habe ich auch was gelernt heute.
Ja, also das übernächstes Jahr kommen soll.
Weltraumverkehrsnachrichten gehört.
Das wird ein 6 Meter Teleskop sein, was natürlich riesig ist für ein Weltraumteleskop.
Was ja auch echt ein bisschen scary ist und echt Angst macht,
weil natürlich 6 Meter Teleskop, das kann ich nicht so, wie es ist,
in den Weltraum schießen. So große Raketen haben wir ja gar nicht.
Das heißt, ich muss das ganze Ding, das ist auch ein segmentierter Hauptspiegel
und das auch noch, der wird dann auch noch zusammengeklappt und dann wird so
im zusammengeklappten, zusammengefalteten Zustand in den Weltraum geschossen
und Und dann muss es sich im Weltraum dann auseinanderklappen.
Und wenn dann irgendwas schief geht, ist es natürlich blöd.
Aber ja, das ist vielleicht klappt, Weltraum. Es wird bestimmt klappen,
weil es im Zweifel nicht zum ersten Mal gemacht wird.
In der Regel ist das, also die Erzählung geht rum, als die Astronomie ein Hubble-Weltraumteleskop
haben wollte, also ein Teleskop von der Größenordnung des Hubbles haben wollte,
sind sie zum Johnson Space Flight Center gegangen und die sind dann über die Straße gegangen,
und sind dann in einen Raum gegangen und dann haben sie gesagt,
welches von den beiden wollte er denn?
Da hingen schon zwei. Also die militärischen Militärs, die haben solche Dinge schon lange gehabt.
Verstehe.
Also das kann man auch schließen. Die gucken natürlich dann in die andere Richtung,
aber sowas gibt es schon.
Und man geht davon aus, das wissen wir natürlich nicht, aber man geht davon
aus, wenn die NASA sagt, wir könnten das und die Astronomen sagen,
wirklich könnt ihr das? du, trust us, wir können das, dann kann man davon ausgehen,
dass wir es schon mal gemacht haben.
Okay, sehr gut.
Muss nur noch der Start funktionieren. Bleiben wir nochmal am Boden.
Also Extremely Large Telescope ist coming und man kann davon ausgehen,
dass noch eine ganze Menge mehr zu sehen ist, aber man hat natürlich immer noch
den Nachteil der eingeschränkten Frequenzen.
Also man hat halt nur sichtbare Licht und im Weltall kann man natürlich sehr
viel mehr sehen. Aber lass mal das mal außen vor.
Jetzt hat ja, also insbesondere die Teleskope von ESO, Very Large Telescope
und die anderen haben ja auch eine ganze Menge Erkenntnisse gebracht.
Ich habe es mir irgendwo notiert, ich weiß es natürlich wieder gerade nicht
auswendig, aber es gab so den einen oder anderen Durchbruch,
Beobachtung von diesen Gamma-Blitzen.
Besonders alte Sterne wurden, also man konnte extrem weit in die Vergangenheit zurückschauen.
Seit den 90er Jahren, seitdem wir quasi mit diesen Großteleskopen auf dem Boden
arbeiten, ist die Gesamterkenntnis Weltraum auch dadurch enorm angewachsen.
Total, absolut. Also die Dinge,
die wir in den letzten 20, 25 Jahren herausgefunden haben, das ist enorm.
Wobei man dabei übrigens betonen sollte auch, dass es tatsächlich ein Zusammenspiel
der verschiedenen Teleskope gegeben hat. Also es hat in den letzten 25 Jahren,
ist das Zusammenspielen der verschiedenen Fähigkeiten der verschiedenen Teleskope,
das hat enorm an Bedeutung gewonnen.
Also Hubble im Weltraum mit den Großteleskopen am Boden, aber auch über die
verschiedenen Frequenzen hinweg, also von Radio, Röntgenstrahlen,
Gamma-Strahlen, das alles zusammengenommen.
UV, das Infrarotstrahlen, das alles zusammengenommen,
das hat so in den letzten 20, 30 Jahren eben zusammengekommen,
diese Multiwellenlängenastronomie, dass man sich eben Daten zu einem Objekt
aus all den verschiedenen Frequenzen eben zusammengenommen hat,
um eben wirklich die Physik dieser Objekte besser verstehen zu können,
das ist so in den letzten 25 Jahren aufgekommen.
Aber es ist richtig, dass eben die Großteleskope natürlich unheimlich viel dazu beigetragen haben.
Stichwort Exoplaneten, 1995 ist der erste Exoplanet, um einen normalen Stern entdeckt worden.
Das übrigens, diese Entdeckung stammt nicht von einem der Großteleskope,
aber natürlich tragen die jetzt heute natürlich viel damit bei.
Also das erste direkte Bild eines Exoplaneten, also eines Planeten,
der einen anderen Stern umkreist.
Das erste direkte Bild eines solchen Exoplaneten ist vom VLT aufgenommen worden.
Wir haben unheimlich viel über Kosmologie gelernt, wir haben unheimlich viel
über die Entwicklung von Galaxien gelernt, wir haben, du hast eben den alten
Stern angesprochen, wir haben Sterne in unserer Milchstraße gefunden,
die zu den allerersten Sternen gehört haben müssen, die in der Milchstraße entstanden sind.
Also um die 13 Milliarden Jahre alt.
Genau, die sehr, sehr alt, ja ganz so alt nicht, aber die sehr, sehr alt geworden sind.
Wir haben zurückblicken können bis an den Anfang des Universums,
haben zwar noch nicht die allerersten Sterne und Galaxien am Anfang des Universums sehen können,
das schaffen diese Teleskope tatsächlich nicht, das wird der neuen Generation
an Teleskopen vorbehalten sein,
aber wir haben mittlerweile Galaxien gesehen, die so weit entfernt sind,
dass das Licht mehr als 13 Milliarden Jahre gebraucht hat, um bis zu uns vorzudringen.
Also das ist echt enorm, was da alles passiert ist.
Wir haben sehr viel über die Struktur unserer eigenen Milchstraße gelernt, wie sie aufgebaut ist.
Und wir haben auch eine Entdeckung aus den 90er Jahren, in den späten 90er Jahren,
ist, dass das Universum sich nicht nur ausdehnt, sondern dass diese Ausdehnung
sich auch noch beschleunigt.
Und das ist eine sehr, sehr merkwürdige Gegebenheit, die zum Nobelpreis von 2011 geführt hat.
Das war der erste Nobelpreis, der sozusagen in die optische Astronomie gegangen
ist, weil das einfach vollkommen unverständlich ist.
Also diese beschleunigte Ausdehnung des Universums bedeutet im Prinzip,
dass wir hier ganz fundamental etwas nicht verstehen in der Physik,
beziehungsweise dass es eine Energiekomponente im Universum gibt,
die wir eben mangels eines besseren Namens dunkle Energie nennen.
Aber das Problem haben, dass diese dunkle Energie überhaupt nicht in unser Standardmodell
der Teilchenphysik reinpasst.
Und also diese ganzen Dinge sind alle erst in den letzten 25 Jahren hochgekommen.
Also der Erkenntnisfortschritt in der Astronomie ist enorm schnell und das liegt
ganz einfach daran, dass die Astronomie ...
Das Entdeckungsstadium, also wissenschaftshistorisch gesehen,
das Entdeckungsstadium noch nicht verlassen hat.
Wir entdecken, ich habe gerade mehrere Beispiele genannt, das waren alles Entdeckungen,
die hatte überhaupt niemand auf dem Schirm.
Das waren alles vollkommen unvorhergesehene Entdeckungen, ausgenommen die Exoplaneten,
die haben natürlich direkt danach gesucht.
Aber viele Entdeckungen sind eben heute noch vollkommen unvorhergesehen.
Das heißt, wir sind noch in diesem Entdeckungsstadium und das bedeutet,
dass in dem Moment, wenn mir die
Technologie neue beobachtungstechnische Möglichkeiten an die Hand gibt,
sprich ich kann entweder ein größeres Teleskop bauen oder kann eine andere Art
von Teleskop in den Weltraum schießen oder eine andere Art von Instrument bauen,
mit dem ich dann eben das Weltall auf eine Art und Weise beobachten kann,
was vorher noch nicht möglich war,
dann entdecken wir jedes Mal, wenn wir so einen Schritt nach vorne machen können,
dann entdecken wir jedes Mal Phänomene, die vorher keiner auf dem Schirm hatte.
Und weil eben der technologische Fortschritt so schnell ist,
ist dementsprechend auch der Erkenntnisgewinn in der Astronomie so schnell.
Und das liegt einfach, wie gesagt, daran, dass wir noch nicht alles im Universum
gesehen haben, was es zu sehen gibt.
Wir sind noch nicht aus dieser Entdeckungsphase raus.
Natürlich sind Studien darüber, wie ein Stern funktioniert, sind natürlich sehr weit fortgeschritten.
Und da geht es natürlich wirklich ums Detail, also um das Detailverständnis
von einzelnen Objekten oder von solchen Galaxien hier. Das ist echt eine.
Geile Animationen hier gerade.
Aber es geht natürlich auch darum, Detailverständnis zu entwickeln,
physikalisches Detailverständnis für einzelne Objekte zu entwickeln.
Aber wir sind, wie gesagt, auf der anderen Seite immer noch in diesem Entdeckermodus.
Und wir bauen eben immer noch Dinge, da sind wir fleißig dran,
das ELT ist ein Beispiel,
aber es gibt noch jede Menge andere neue Teleskope, die in den nächsten 10,
15 Jahren online kommen werden, die eben auch diesen Schritt nach vorne machen
und auch eben das Universum auf eine Art und Weise beobachten werden,
die wir heute noch nicht beherrschen.
Und das wird garantiert noch zu ganz großen Dingen führen.
Dass so technologische Entwicklungen manchmal so einen Punkt überschreiten,
ab dem es dann nicht nur ein bisschen besser wird, sondern weil man einfach
genau diesen Punkt passiert hat,
auf einmal Dinge, ganz grundsätzliche Dinge möglich werden, die ja vorher so noch vielleicht auch,
die vielleicht angedacht waren, Manchmal auch überraschend kommen,
aber so gibt es ja dieses schöne englische Wort Threshold, für den ich richtig
keinen guten deutschen Begriff finde.
Also dieser Knackpunkt sozusagen, den man dann überschreitet,
ab dem dann auf einmal alles wieder ganz anders ist.
Da gab es ja nun gerade vor zwei Jahren so ein schönes Ereignis,
wo genau das erreicht wurde.
Ein Instrumentarium wurde verbessert, die Messqualität wurde abermals verdoppelt
und zack, bumm, auf einmal konnte man Gravitationswellen messen.
Eine Nachricht, die ja weit um den Planeten herumgegangen ist,
hier auch bei Raumzeit, gab es ein sehr ausführliches Gespräch zu dem Thema,
auch gerade in der letzten Folge, wo ich mich zufälligerweise übrigens über
Neutronensterne unterhalten habe.
Wie passend.
Genau in dieser Woche, als dann das Ereignis antrat, was wir uns jetzt sicherlich
nochmal unterhalten werden, sprich Gravitationswellenmessung war lange,
lange Zeit so ein Ding, wo man eben nicht wusste,
wird es irgendwann mal passieren?
Also es gab ein paar Begeisterte, die so, ja, das kriegen wir schon irgendwie
hin, lass uns nur mal machen.
Und die anderen so, naja, ihr macht das jetzt schon seit 50 Jahren und so.
Und Einstein hat ja schon gesagt, das kriegt ihr nie hin.
Hat aber funktioniert jetzt. Also hat nicht nur funktioniert,
sondern hat ja dann auch gleich in dem Moment,
also man hat es ja gerade mal eingeschaltet gehabt und einen Tag später kam
dann sozusagen schon das erste Ereignis,
auf das man jetzt seit 100 Jahren gewartet hat und dann war es halt nicht nur
so, dass man irgendwie was gemessen hat, sondern man hat genau das gemessen,
was man vorher ausgerechnet hat und es sah auch genau so aus und man wusste sofort,
oh wow, das funktioniert und das kommt ja jetzt im Prinzip auch noch dazu.
Genau, das ist der große Übergang, die Schwelle, an der wir jetzt stehen.
Ich habe vorhin davon gesprochen, dass wir
in den letzten 20 Jahren die Multiwellenlängenastronomie gemacht haben.
Also früher gab es Wellenlängenschauvinismus in der Astronomie.
Also entweder man war mal ein Radioastronom oder man war eben optischer Astronom
und dann hat man mit den anderen gar nicht geredet.
Ach, die Infraroten, die sitzen da hinten.
Die sehen sowieso nichts.
Ist viel zu warm, aber egal.
Und jeder hat so sein eigenes Süppchen gekocht und dann ist man natürlich,
je mehr man die Dinge verstanden hat und je mehr man die physikalischen Prozesse
verstanden hat, die hinter dieser Strahlung, die wir da empfangen,
die dahinter stecken, ist man dann eben auf den Trichter gekommen,
dass man, wenn man zum Beispiel ein Objekt, das so komplex ist wie eine Galaxie,
wirklich verstehen möchte und komplett verstehen möchte, dann braucht man tatsächlich
alle Wellenlängen, um wirklich alle physikalischen Prozesse,
die da ablaufen, abdecken zu können und untersuchen zu können.
Das war also das Zeitalter der Multiwellenlängen-Astronomie.
Und wo wir jetzt stehen ist sozusagen oder wo wir eigentlich jetzt schon eingetreten
sind, ist das Zeitalter der...
Auf Englisch sagt man halt der Multi-Messenger-Astronomy. Also,
dass wir jetzt eben verschiedene Informationsträger benutzen,
um das Universum zu erforschen.
Viele Botschafter.
Viele Botschafter, genau. Was sind denn die Informationsträger?
Wie können wir denn Informationen über das Universum überhaupt rankommen?
Kann man sich ja nochmal einen Schritt zurücknehmen und da mal ganz fundamental
drüber nachdenken. Naja, klar, ich kann natürlich versuchen,
direkt irgendwo hinzufliegen.
Kann ein Rover, eine Rakete irgendwo hinschicken. Klar, das funktioniert nur
in unserem Sommensystem, in unmittelbarer Umgebung.
Und dann haben wir natürlich Licht, sprich elektromagnetische Strahlung.
Das ist die klassische Astronomie, wo wir die ganze Zeit jetzt darüber geredet haben.
Aber dann gibt es ja noch andere Boten. Es kommen zu uns noch Neutrinos.
Neutrinos haben die blöde Eigenschaft, dass sie nur über die schwache Wechselwirkung
mit überhaupt irgendwas wechselwirken.
Das bedeutet, wie der Name schon andeutet, dass sie unheimlich schwierig zu detektieren sind.
Aber wir haben mittlerweile auch große Neutrino-Detektoren,
da vor allem zu nennen Ice Cube am Südpol ist das installiert,
da ist wohl quasi ein Kubikkilometer Eis eingeschmolzen worden und dann hat
man da Dinger reingehängt und das wieder zufrieren lassen.
Mit Ice Cube benutzt man sozusagen ein Kubikkilometer Eis, um Neutrinos zu detektieren.
Und auch das funktioniert mittlerweile. Aber wie gesagt, die Neutrinos sind
sehr, sehr schwer nachzuweisen.
Also da sind wir noch so ein bisschen am Anfang. Dann gibt es die kosmische Strahlung.
Also ich dachte mal, Neutrinos wären überhaupt nicht zu kriegen.
Überhaupt nicht zu kriegen ist nicht richtig, nur sehr schwer.
Also es ist tatsächlich so, dass durch jeden Quadratzentimeter deiner Haut...
Funktioniert ja der alte Barwitz nicht mehr. ein Neutrino kommt in eine Bar, keiner reagiert.
Wenn halt einige Milliarden Neutrinos reinkommen, dann reagiert,
kann unter Umständen mal jemand einem was reagiert.
Die Eiswürfel.
Genau, genau. Also die sind schwer nachzuweisen, aber ja, wie gesagt,
in dem ersten Data Release von IceCube waren, lass mich nicht lügen,
aber ich glaube 30 Detektionen, also 30 Neutrinos wurden da.
Also das waren so wenige, dass sie alle Namen hatten.
Berühmtes Beispiel sind Ernie und Bert.
Tatsächlich?
Ja.
Wow.
Egal. Also die Neutrinos.
Hat man den gar nicht angesehen.
Und dann gibt es die kosmische Strahlung. Das ist also, tatsächlich sind sehr
energiereiche Partikel.
Die sind so energiereich, dass ich da selbst im LAC solche Energien nicht erreichen kann.
Und wenn solche Partikel auf die Erdatmosphäre treffen, dann passieren alle
möglichen Sekundärschauer und Lichtblitze und Pipapo, was da alles losgeht.
Das kann ich versuchen zu beobachten. Nicht nur versuchen, das kann man auch.
Das gibt es das Pierre-Orger-Observatorium in der argentinischen pampa womit
man das beobachten kann das blöde an den der kosmische strahlung ist es sind
tatsächlich geladene teilchen und geladene teilchen haben nun mal die blöde
eigenschaft dass sie von,
magnetfeldern abgelenkt werden können und magnetfelder gibt es überall auch
seien sie auch noch so schwach aber wenn ich eben jetzt ein kosmisches teilchen
von dort drüben empfangen dann kann ich mir ziemlich sicher sein dass es nicht,
ursprünglich aus dieser richtung kam sondern irgendwie also irgendeinen komplizierten
fahrt durchs um die nasen genommen hat aber auch das wird mittlerweile gemacht,
Und dann gibt es eben noch die angesprochenen Gravitationswellen,
die wir jetzt eben neuerdings in der Lage sind, direkt zu detektieren.
Wir wussten eigentlich schon, dass es sie gibt aus einer indirekten Beobachtung,
die schon einige Jahre zurückliegt.
Aber jetzt können wir sie eben direkt beobachten und können eben einzelne Events,
wie zum Beispiel das Verschmelzen von zwei schwarzen Löchern,
solche einzelnen Events wahrnehmen.
Und das war natürlich eine Riesensensation, dass das überhaupt erstmal möglich war.
Wie gesagt, du hast es angesprochen und eben richtig beschrieben.
Die Leute haben zum Teil Jahrzehnte daran gearbeitet, also das LIGO-Team.
Es war also eine komplette Karriere da reingeflossen, um das technisch möglich zu machen.
Jetzt geht es eben mittlerweile. Und die große Frage war eben,
was würde man dort sehen?
Also was würde man sehen, wenn man dann irgendwann die Sensitivität erreicht hat?
Was würde man sehen? Also was jetzt gesehen wurde, sind die Kollisionen von
zwei schwarzen Löchern, die 10, 20, 30 Sonnenmassen haben.
Gerade heute kam ein neues Paper raus von zwei, eine neue Detektion aus dem
Juni glaube ich oder Juli, wo zwei schwarze Löcher, ich glaube eins hatte nur
neun Sonnenmassen und das andere zehn oder irgendwie sowas, also relativ kleine Sonnensterne.
Aber die große Frage war, man wusste ja überhaupt nicht, wie viele schwarze
Löcher in der Größenordnung gibt es denn überhaupt.
Und es hätte eben sein können, dass es nur sehr, sehr wenige gibt,
sodass ich nur eine Kollision in zehn Jahren sehe, dass wir dann...
Langwierig gewesen.
Oder beziehungsweise es hätte eben auch sein können, dass es davon so viele
gibt, dass ich einzelne Events gar nicht auseinanderhalten kann,
sondern dass es die ganze Zeit macht und ich quasi wie,
eine Teichüberfläche, wie ein Teich, in dem ich jetzt eine ganze Handvoll Kieselsteine
reinwerfe, alles nur noch macht und ich gar nichts mehr, einzelne Events gar
nicht mehr auseinanderhalten kann, weil ich also sozusagen sofort nur noch rauschen sehe.
Aber glücklicherweise ist weder das eine noch das andere entspricht der Realität
und die Realität ist tatsächlich so, dass wir eben einzelne Events sehen können,
auseinanderhalten und das mit einer Frequenz, die sehr angenehm zu beobachten ist.
Das heißt, man sieht tatsächlich, mittlerweile haben wir jetzt glaube ich fünf
Detektionen insgesamt, wenn ich das von heute mit dazu zähle.
Und was jetzt ganz eben kürzlich passiert ist.
Also in einem anderthalb Jahr oder so, oder zwei Jahre sind es jetzt so.
Ja, ja, wobei man dazu sagen muss, dass die Instrumente nicht durchlaufen.
Die werden immer zwischendurch immer mal wieder abgeschaltet,
weil eben Wartungsarbeiten oder Verbesserungen durchgeführt werden müssen.
Also die laufen nicht komplett durch.
Aber es gibt jetzt drei davon.
Ja, fünf glaube ich mittlerweile sogar. Fünf in Betrieben, ja.
Sorry, du meinst Instrumente jetzt in Betrieb.
Ja.
Ich dachte Detektion. Ja, es gibt also die zwei in Amerika, die nach wie vor laufen.
Und es wird in, es gibt eben dann noch eins in Norditalien, das ist die europäische Komponente,
also LIGO sind die beiden in Amerika und dann gibt es eben Virgo,
das in der Nähe von Pisa steht, in der Po-Ebene in Norditalien und es werden
weitere gebaut, also es wird sowohl in Indien als auch in Japan werden noch weitere,
entstehen, noch genau, das ist halt so super.
Weil man dann also beim ersten Event wusste man ja nur, es waren zwei schwarze
Löcher, wir haben sie mit Sicherheit gesehen, wir können das beweisen,
aber wir wussten halt nicht, wo das ist, weil man nur so Annahmen darüber,
so grobe Annahmen darüber macht.
Ja, man wusste nur nicht sehr genau, wo es ist. Also man hatte einen Fehlerbalken
am Himmel, der etwa 600 Quadratgrad entsprach.
Das war halt ein ziemlich grobe, also es gab eine grobe Gegend,
es kam ungefähr aus dieser Richtung am Himmel.
Man wusste, von welcher Seite der Erde es kam.
Ja, ein bisschen besser als das, aber man konnte es nicht pinpointen,
man konnte nicht sagen, es kam aus dieser Galaxie oder aus der Erde.
Genau, aber jetzt mit dem dritten Messgerät, was sozusagen dann auch dieses
Neutronensternereignis gemessen hat, konnte man halt sehr viel genauer schauen.
Genau, je mehr man hat, desto genauer kann man die Richtung,
aus der, oder die Richtung, in der dieses Event stattgefunden hat, kann man die festlegen.
Und was eben jetzt passiert ist, was noch dazu kam, ist eben,
dass zum ersten Mal das, das, was die Gravitationswellen verursacht hat,
wir eben auch in elektromagnetischer Strahlung gesehen haben. Also den ersten,
Den ersten Gravitationswellenevent waren, wie gesagt, zwei schwarze Löcher von
der Größenordnung von 30 Sonnenmassen, die sich miteinander verschmolzen haben.
Man hat natürlich, nachdem das gemessen wurde, hat man mit jedem Teleskop dieser
Welt in diese Richtung gekocht und hat versucht abzusuchen, wo das ist.
Obwohl man eben nicht genau wusste, wo es war, aber zumindest kennt man die
Distanz, aus der es kommt.
Und schwarze Löcher sind ja jetzt nicht so.
Man hat also alles abgesucht und man hat nichts gefunden.
Und das war schon mal erstmal ein bisschen komisch, aber was uns das wiederum
zeigte, war, dass die Gravitationswellen uns tatsächlich einen Teil des Universums
zeigen können, den wir in elektromagnetischer Strahlung überhaupt nicht zu Gesicht bekommen.
Also es gibt Phänomene da draußen, die wir mit herkömmlichen Teleskopen überhaupt
nicht beobachten können, die wir nur in Gravitationswellen zu sehen kriegen.
Und jetzt hatten wir eben, was jetzt eben passiert ist, dass wir ein Event gesehen
haben, wo eben zwei Neutronensterne miteinander verschmolzen sind und diesen
Event konnte man sehr wohl auch in elektromagnetischer Strahlung sehen.
Also dieser Event wurde zuerst eben auch als sogenannter Gamma-Ray-Blitz,
also als Gammastrahlenblitz wahrgenommen.
Dieser Gammastrahlenblitz traf zwei Sekunden nach den Gravitationswellen hier an der Erde ein.
Und dann ist man eben dann auch mit optischen und sämtlichen anderen Teleskopen
hingegangen und hat wiederum diese Richtung am Himmel abgesucht und hat tatsächlich
diesmal es genau pinpointen können, wo das passiert ist.
Was hat denn den Gamma-Blitz gesehen? Ich meine, das kann jetzt keine unmittelbare
Reaktion auf die Messung gewesen sein, weil die wird zwar gemessen,
aber bis man diese Information hat, vergeht ja einiges.
Es gibt Satelliten, also es gibt Gamma-Strahlen, Teleskope im Weltraum,
die nach diesen Gamma-Blitzen Ausschau halten.
Das war eine völlig separate Detektion, also die haben es gemessen,
die haben es gemessen und sind dann sehr schnell auf den Trichter gekommen,
dass es das gleiche Event war, dass es ungefähr aus der gleichen Richtung kam.
Und dann hat man eben mit optischen Teleskopen die Galaxie identifizieren können,
in der das passierte und in dieser Galaxie gab es tatsächlich eben eine neue
Punktquelle, die aufgeleuchtet war, die vorher nicht da war und genau diese
Punktquelle, das war dann die sogenannte Kilonova,
also das war das optische pendant zu diesem Neutronenstern, zu dieser Neutronensternverschmelzung.
Und diese Neutronenverschmelzung, die hat man eben, wie gesagt,
sowohl in Gravitationswellen gesehen, als auch hat sie eben einen Gammastrahlenblitz
ausgelöst, als auch aber eben optisches Licht ausgesandt. Das kann man eben
alles jetzt zusammen sehen.
Und das ist eben genau das, was ich von dem hier eben sprach.
Das ist jetzt eben so richtig echtes Multi-Messenger-Astronomie.
Das ist die neue Ära, in die wir jetzt eingetreten sind.
Ja, Jochen, ich glaube langsam müssen wir mal zum Ende kommen,
so spannend und interessant das auch alles ist.
Vielleicht nochmal so zum Ausklagen, auch an das anschließen,
also ich meine gerade jetzt diese Sache mit dem Neutronenstern,
das war jetzt eine dicke Nummer, jetzt kommen irgendwie neue Sachen.
Mit Erwartungshaltung ist es immer so ein bisschen schwierig,
aber was steht uns noch bevor?
Also was sind denn so die nächsten Rätsel, die jetzt gelöst werden müssen oder
die sich geradezu anbieten?
Unter anderem jetzt durch die neue Technologie im Bereich bodengestützter Teleskope
im Zusammenhang vielleicht auch eben mit den anderen Botschaftern. Worauf warten wir?
Also mit den anderen Botschaftern zusammen, also vor allem mit den Gravitationswellen
zusammen, werden wir jetzt den ganzen Zoo an kompakten Objekten,
die es da draußen gibt, also mit kompakten Objekten meint man schwarze Löcher,
Neutronensterne, das wird man jetzt zum ersten Mal Einblick da rein gewinnen,
was es da eigentlich alles draußen gibt,
bei welchen Massen es wie viele von solchen Objekten gibt.
Diese Sternleichen zu sehen, wie überhaupt diese.
Mittelgroßen schwarzen Löcher überhaupt entstanden sind, das erzählt uns vielleicht
ein bisschen was darüber und hilft uns darüber, dabei zu verstehen,
wie diese riesen schwarzen Löcher, die in den Zentren von Galaxien sitzen, die sogenannten.
Supermassiven schwarzen Löcher, die eine Million oder sogar eine Milliarde Sonnenmassen,
Overwhelmingly Large Black Holes. Black Holes, genau.
Wie die denn wohl entstanden sein könnten, das könnte womöglich ein Schlüssel dazu sein.
Aber was eben auch in der Planung oder groß auf dem Zettel steht und ganz oben
eben auf der Wunschliste der Astronomen steht,
sind so ein bisschen am entgegengesetzten Ende der Größenskala,
einmal bei der Kosmologie und einmal bei den Exoplaneten.
Bei den Exoplaneten geht ganz klar mittlerweile jetzt eben der Drang dahin oder
geht die Forschung eben in die Richtung, nicht mehr jetzt nur noch quasi Exoplaneten
zu sammeln und zu gucken, wie viele gibt es eigentlich und wie viel pro Sterne gibt es,
sondern dahin zu gehen, zu gucken, welche Eigenschaften diese Planeten wirklich haben.
Und insbesondere auch dahin zu gehen, ob man eben Atmosphären um diese Planeten
herum detektieren kann, das können wir zum Teil sogar schon,
aber eben natürlich ist der heilige Gral, ist da natürlich erdähnliche Planeten
zu finden und deren Atmosphären zu charakterisieren, um natürlich….
Womöglich eines Tages etwas darüber aussagen zu können, ob auf einem dieser
Planeten es tatsächlich Leben geben könnte.
Und wir wissen ziemlich genau, wie man das machen kann.
Wir wissen, dass auf der Erde das weit verbreitete Auftreten von Leben an der
Erdoberfläche hat die Zusammensetzung der Erdatmosphäre beeinflusst.
Die Erdatmosphäre war nicht immer so sauerstaufreich, wie es ja heute ist.
Das kam erst durch die Erfindung der So-Photosynthese sozusagen zustande.
Und man muss davon ausgehen oder kann davon ausgehen, dass es eben auf anderen
Planeten auch der Fall sein würde.
Also man kann eben aus bestimmten Markern in der Zusammensetzung einer Atmosphäre
womöglich eben darauf schließen, dass es auf einem solchen Exoplaneten womöglich Leben geben könnte.
Und das werden wir, darauf können wir uns glaube ich alle freuen,
das werden wir wahrscheinlich viele von uns hier in diesem Raum,
die meisten von uns in diesem Raum werden das meines Erachtens noch erleben.
Dass wir also tatsächlich außerirdisches Leben noch bis zu einem gewissen Sicherheitsgrad
noch nachweisen können.
Das ist das eine. Und das andere, am anderen Ende der Skala eben in der Kosmologie
geht es nach wie vor darum zu bestimmen, was ist dunkle Materie,
können wir darüber was aussagen und eben was ist diese womöglich noch viel mysteriöse
dunkle Energie, die unser Universum auseinander treibt und die die Beschleunigung
des Universums noch antreibt.
Da gibt es jede Menge Dinge, die in der Mache sind, jede Menge neue Teleskope,
die in der Mache sind, neue Weltraumteleskope, aber auch neue Experimente,
die auf dem Boden geplant werden.
Und auch da werden wir hoffentlich in den nächsten 20 Jahren noch eine ganze Menge rausfinden.
Und das sind so zwei der Highlights, auf die ich mich besonders freue.
Das sind ja super Ausblicke, Johann. Ich sage vielen Dank für die Ausführungen
hier bei Raumzeit und ich sage, das war es.
Das war die heutige Ausgabe hier live aus dem Zeiss Großplanetarium in Berlin.
Ich bedanke mich bei allen, die gekommen sind und bei allen,
die auch weiterhin diesen Podcast hören und unterstützen und sage Tschüss und bis bald.
Vielen Dank.